I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hey gang. Hey everybody. We are here this week to finish talking about launch party. It's launch party part two. And it is a launch party of the Dunder Mifflin Infinity website. It's a big deal. Jinx. Buy me a Coke. It's season four, episode six, written by Jen Salata and directed by Ken Whittingham. Here is a summary. Do it. This week, Michael returns
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。大家好。我们这周来到这里，继续讨论发布会派对。这是发布会派对（下）。这是邓德米夫林无限公司网站的发布派对。这可是件大事。乌鸦嘴。请我喝可乐吧。这是第四季第六集，由詹·萨拉塔编剧，肯·威廷汉执导。以下是剧情梗概。开始吧。这周，迈克尔回来了
to Scranton after realizing he was not invited to the big New York launch party for Dunder Mifflin Infinity, but instead he has to celebrate via webcam. So he decides to ramp up the launch party in Scranton and he gives Angela a very long list of demands. Then he orders pizza. Right. When the pizza delivery guy refuses to honor Michael's half off coupon, he holds him hostage in the conference room. Meanwhile, Andy tries to woo Angela to the dismay of Dwight. Does he? He's relentless and a little charming and a little charming and a little douchey. We'll get there. All right. Fast fact number one, we have a big guest star alert. Yes. We're so excited, you guys. The pizza delivery guy was played by Kevin McHale. Now,
在意识到自己没有受到邀请去纽约参加邓德米夫林无限公司的大型纽约发布会后，他回到了斯克兰顿，取而代之的是他只能通过网络摄像头庆祝。于是他决定在斯克兰顿大肆操办发布会，并给安吉拉列了一大长串要求。接着他点了披萨。没错。当披萨外卖小哥拒绝接受迈克尔的五折优惠券时，他在会议室里把对方劫为人质。与此同时，安吉拉在德怀特的苦恼下，试图赢得安吉拉的芳心。是吗？他坚持不懈，有点迷人，有点迷人，又有点混账。我们待会儿会说到这儿。好啦，趣事一号，我们有一个大牌客串明星预警。是的。我们太激动了，伙计们。披萨外卖小哥由凯文·麦克海尔饰演。现在，
you guys probably know Kevin because he would go on to be a regular on the TV show Glee. But this was about two years before that happened. This appearance on the office was one of his first television acting jobs. So we reached out to him to hear how it all went down. Yeah. Kevin, thanks for letting me slide into your DMs. Angela really slid into his DMs, guys. I always feel so weird, but he's a very nice person. I was like, Hey, Angela and Jenna here. Hello. And he was wonderful. He sent us an audio clips. And here is what he had to say, you guys, about coming in to audition for the role. It's so charming. Sam, can you play that clip? So what I remember about the audition is actually the callback because the initial audition, no
大家可能认识凯文，因为他后来成为了电视剧《欢乐合唱团》的常驻演员。但这大约发生在那两年之前。他在《办公室》中的这次亮相是他最早的电视表演工作之一。所以我们联系了他，听听这一切是如何进行的。是的。凯文，谢谢你让我溜进你的私信。安吉拉真的溜进了他的私信，伙计们。我总是觉得很诡异，但他是个非常好的人。我说，嘿，安吉拉和珍娜在这儿。你好。他太棒了。他给我们发了一段音频。伙计们，以下是他关于来试镜这个角色的看法。太迷人了。萨姆，你能播放那段音频吗？关于试镜，我记得的其实是复试，因为初试，完全没
memory, but the callback I was waiting in the stairwell. It was me and Dave Franco and a couple other guys. And then one of the casting assistants comes out and says, Oh, we're going to start in a few minutes, but we just have to wait for Steve. And I'm someone who has terrible, terrible nerves. And I don't know if my manager didn't know and didn't tell me, but I was very unaware that Steve Krill was going to read with us for the callback. And I went in. I sat there and tried with all my might just to get the words out. And at some point, Steve Krill, like chuckled, looked at the casting director and they chuckled. And I was like, Oh my God, I made him laugh. And that was it. Like, I, if I didn't get the job, I was happy enough just with that, that I made he and Alison Jones
记忆，但复试时我在楼梯间等候。当时只有我和戴夫·弗兰科还有另外几个人。然后一个选角助理走出来说，哦，我们几分钟后开始，但我们得等一下史蒂夫。而我是一个极度紧张、神经衰弱的人。我不知道是不是我的经纪人不知道也没告诉我，但我完全不知道史蒂夫·卡瑞尔会来和我们一起复试。然后我进去了。我坐在那儿，拼尽全力才把台词说出口。然后在某个时刻，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔发出一声轻笑，看了看选角导演，他们都笑了。当时我就想，哦，天哪，我逗笑了。就是这样。哪怕我没得到这份工作，仅仅因为我逗笑了他和艾莉森·琼斯，我就已经足够高兴了。
laugh. But who, by the way, Alison Jones, the casting director, she was the first casting director to just continuously give me a chance when I hadn't worked or booked anything. And she kept getting me further and further along in these jobs, like this or super bad. And she just kept putting me in the room. And I have her to thank for giving me any confidence to even continue to pursue acting at all. That's Alison Jones. Yeah. And then also Steve, just so gracious coming there for those callbacks and being there in the scene with him like that. I mean, I just loved that story. But I see why they asked Steve to pop in on this audition because the pizza delivery guy, it's all
不过说起来，艾莉森·琼斯，这位选角导演，她是第一个在我还没工作过、也没接到过任何工作时，就不断给我机会的选角导演。她不断让我在这些工作中越走越远，比如这个或者《太坏了》。她只是不断把我推到试镜房间里。我真得感谢她给了我继续追求表演事业的哪怕一丝信心。这就是艾莉森·琼斯。是的。还有史蒂夫，他能来参加复试并和他在场景里那样，真的太亲切了。我的意思是，我太喜欢这个故事了。但我明白他们为什么请史蒂夫顺便来参加这次试镜了，因为披萨外卖小哥，全都是
him and Steve and rain. Yeah. And Steve was a big star. And the last thing you want to do is hire someone and bring them to set. And then they freeze up because they're now performing not with a casting associate, but with this big star. So he did it. He made it through and he got the job. Yeah, I like when he said I was just concentrating on getting the words out. Well, he does a great, great job in this part. And guys, he sent in a few other audio clips that will sprinkle in throughout the episode. Yeah. All right. So what's your fast fact number two? Okay, my fast fact number two, and when I was researching this episode, I was going through my archives and all this stuff started popping up from
他和史蒂夫还有雷恩。对。而且史蒂夫是个大明星。你最不想做的事就是雇一个人把他带到片场。然后他们因为现在不是跟选角助理对戏，而是跟这个大明星对戏而当场大脑一片空白。所以他做到了。他挺过来了，得到了这份工作。对，我喜欢他说我当时只是集中精力把台词说出来的部分。嗯，他在这个角色里表现得非常非常棒。而且伙计们，他还发来了其他几段音频，我们会在整集节目中穿插播放。是的。好吧，那你的趣事二号是什么？好吧，我的趣事二号是，当我在调研这一集时，我翻看我的档案，所有这些东西都开始涌现出来，来自
the 2007 Emmy Awards. Yes. Oh, that was a fun one. Yes, we shot this episode right around the same time as the Emmys. And this was the year that I was nominated. I know it was a big deal. We were so excited. It was so cool. And I found a blog that I wrote on MySpace about getting the nomination. And it's so cute. I got to hear the old ye olde MySpace blog. Let's hear it. Here's what I wrote. Man, I am so excited. I just can't tell you what this means to me. Not because it is an award or something like that, but because it feels like it's for our gal Pam. She's a shy girl who doesn't get recognized very often, you know, it's like that shot from the episode with the art show where Pam is standing in front of her display waiting for the first visitor to come by. That just sums it all up for me. So I
2007年的艾美奖。是的。哦，那真是个有趣的日子。是的，我们拍摄这一集的时间差不多就在艾美奖同期。这也是我被提名的那一年。我知道，这可是件大事。我们太兴奋了。太酷了。我翻到了一篇我在MySpace上写的关于获得提名的博客。太可爱了。我得听听老派的MySpace博客。我们听听吧。这是我写的。天哪，我太激动了。我简直无法表达这对我的意义。不是因为它是一个奖项什么的，而是因为这感觉像是为了我们的好闺蜜帕姆。她是个不常被认可的害羞女孩，你知道的，就像艺术展那一集里的那个镜头，帕姆站在她的展品前等待第一个参观者光临。这对我来说简直就是全部的写照。所以我想
guess I feel it in that part of me that is Pam, the part that still gets excited to show my art and no people are responding to it. It's like, Hey, people showed up to my art show. Oh, that is so sweet, Jenna. And you know what? I remember I did not win the Emmy. And I remember thinking like, damn it, I wanted Pam to go up there and get her trophy. It was like her Dundee's moment. I really wanted to say I feel God in this Emmy's tonight. I know you were so excited. You had your opening line. It was gonna crush. You would have crushed it. I would have crushed it. But lady, you were my plus one. I know I was about to say I remember this year because you had a really hot date. It was me. We got to go together and it was a blast. But it was also if you remember Angela, it was in the
我能感同身受，在那个作为帕姆的自己心里，那个依然为展示自己的艺术、看到人们对此有反应而感到兴奋的自我。就像，嘿，有人来看我的艺术展了。哦，太甜了，珍娜。你知道吗？我记得我没有赢得艾美奖。我记得当时想的是，操，我真想让帕姆上台去拿她的奖杯。那就像是她的邓迪奖时刻。我真的很想说，我今晚在艾美奖感受到了上帝。我知道你当时太兴奋了。你准备好了开场白。绝对会大获成功的。你本可以惊艳全场的。我本可以惊艳全场的。但是亲爱的，你是我的女伴。我知道，我正想说，我记得这一年，因为你有一个非常辣的约会对象。那就是我。我们一起去了，玩得超开心。但如果你还记得的话，安吉拉，这也是
round. I will never forget it. It was so bizarre. So you know, normally the Emmys is like in a traditional type theater where you sit in theater style seating, right? One row in front of the other. Well, this year, it's like the television Academy decided to mix it up. And they put the seats in a circle in the stage in the middle, a big circle. So it was like theater in the round. And Jenna, I remember where we were seated. Oh, I knew the minute we took our seats, I wasn't going to win. Oh, honey. We were in the back of the circle. So we faced everyone's butt all night. All night. We just saw a real fancy people's asses. That's what we saw. And we kept thinking at some point, are they going to turn around and face our section? No, never once. The entire thing was
环形座位的。我永远不会忘记。太诡异了。你知道的，通常艾美奖是在传统的剧院里，你坐在剧院式的座位上，对吧？一排在另一排前面。然而今年，就像是电视艺术与科学学院决定搞点新花样。他们把座位围成一个圈，舞台在中间，一个大圆圈。所以就像环形剧场一样。珍娜，我还记得我们的座位在哪儿。哦，我们一落座我就知道我不会赢了。哦，亲爱的。我们在圆圈的背面。所以我们整晚都对着所有人的屁股。整晚。我们看到的都是有钱人的屁股。这就是我们看到的。我们一直觉得在某个时刻，他们会转过身来面对我们这一片区域吗？不，一次也没有。整场颁奖典礼
performed as if there were not people sitting behind the speaker. It was so bizarre. And you know, sometimes someone who would win would like sort of glance over their shoulder like, Hey, guys, how are you back there? And we would get so excited. We're like, we're good. We're good. Hi. But yeah, it just was an evening of fancy TV butts. That's what yeah, it was very funny. But something else I noticed when I was seeing all these photos pop up from this time, Angela, was that my back was still not healed at the time. And there were a lot of restrictions on what I was allowed to wear and not wear. I couldn't wear anything that was too tight on my rib cage, too tight on my waist. And I could not wear high heels. So I have all these pictures of us on
的表现就好像坐在发言人身后根本没有人一样。太诡异了。你知道的，有时某个获奖者会有点回头看一眼，就像，嘿，伙计们，你们在后面怎么样？我们会变得超级激动。我们就像，我们很好。我们很好。嗨。但，是的，那真是一个充满高级电视屁股的夜晚。就是这样，是的，非常搞笑。但当我看到这些照片从那个时期涌现出来时，我注意到的另一件事，安吉拉，那就是我的背当时还没有完全康复。对于我被允许穿什么和不被允许穿什么，有很多限制。我不能穿任何对我的胸腔太紧、对我的腰部太紧的衣服。而且我不能穿高跟鞋。所以我保留了所有这些我们在
different red carpets. Yeah, going to the various, you know, pre events, events and things, where I'm wearing these baggy dresses and like bejeweled flip flops. Yes. Yes. And I mean, I just felt like in that moment, you were like family for me. Because my sisters love a bejeweled flip flop. They love it. Yeah, I wore bejeweled flip flops to the 2007 Emmy Awards. And you got to look at people's butts. There you go. It was a special time. I was really bummed you didn't win though. And I, I have no poker face. It's like when Steve didn't win year after year, you know, it's a good thing the camera's not on me or whips away fast because it's all across my face. It's what the you know, they really missed an opportunity for some good television by not having a camera on
不同红毯上的照片。是的，去各种，你知道的，活动前的活动等等，我穿着宽松的裙子，还踩着镶钻的人字拖。是的。是的。我的意思是，我只是觉得在那个时刻，你就像我的家人一样。因为我的姐姐们超爱镶钻人字拖。她们超爱。是的，我穿着镶钻人字拖去参加了2007年的艾美奖。而你却得盯着别人的屁股看。就是这样。那是一段特殊的时光。不过你没能获奖，我真的觉得挺遗憾的。而且我，我完全不会掩饰情绪。就像史蒂夫年复一年没有获奖时一样，你知道的，还好摄像机没有对着我，或者镜头没有迅速切走，因为全写在我的脸上了。你知道的，他们真的错过了一个展现好节目的大好机会，那就是没有把摄像头对准
you every time one of us lost. Oh yeah. That's the before the day of like the memes. My face would have been a meme. For sure. For sure. All right, lady. Well, I'm going to move us on to fast fact number three, because I've got a great big surprise for you. I know you've been a little braggy about this in text to me leading up. She's like, just wait for fast back number three. I'm like, okay, what is it? I got the deep dive on Pam's plants. Shut up. Shut up. I know everything about Pam's plants and who's responsible for them. Oh my gosh, I have to tell you, I was texting with Jen Salata last night. And Jen texted me, she said, And I didn't even know that Pam had a plant at front reception until I started listening to your podcast. I need to know all of this. What? What? What?
我们每次有谁落败时的表情。哦，是的。那是Meme（表情包）盛行之前的日子。我的脸绝对会被做成表情包。肯定的。肯定的。好吧，亲爱的。嗯，我要把我们带到趣事三号，因为我给你准备了一个超级大惊喜。我知道你在之前的短信里对我吹嘘过这个。她就像，等着看趣事三号吧。我就像，好吧，是什么？我拿到了关于帕姆植物的深度内幕。闭嘴。闭嘴。我知道关于帕姆植物的一切以及谁在负责它们。哦，天哪，我得告诉你，我昨晚给詹·萨拉塔发了短信。詹给我发短信说，我甚至不知道前台接待处有一株帕姆的植物，直到我开始听你们的播客。我需要知道这一切。什么？什么？什么？
Tell me. All right, I reached out to our set designer, Michael Gallenberg. Yes. Who told me it was Steve Dusharer. Steve. The lead set dresser. Yes. Who was in charge of Pam's plants. I had a feeling it would be him because he sort of like set that whole area every day. Yes. Well, I called Steve. You did? Angela. Yes, we had the best conversation. So I remembered Steve mainly as the guy who was always having to deal with our computers. Yes, he would come and also like if our lamps went out or yeah, sort of like all the things on our desk that needed attention. Yeah. Well, I told Steve that because he said, Jenna, do you remember me? And I said, Yes, Steve, my memory of you is that you were always crouching under my desk dealing with my computer. And he laughed so hard. He said, Well,
告诉我。好吧，我联系了我们的布景设计师，迈克尔·加伦贝格。是的。他告诉我那是史蒂夫·杜沙尔。史蒂夫。首席布景师。是的。他负责帕姆的植物。我当时就觉得会是他，因为他差不多每天都要布置那个整个区域。是的。嗯，我给史蒂夫打了电话。真的吗？安吉拉。是的，我们进行了最棒的对话。所以我主要把史蒂夫记作那个总是得处理我们的电脑的人。是的，他会过来，还有如果我们的台灯坏了或者，是的，差不多就是我们桌上所有需要关注的东西。嗯，我告诉史蒂夫，因为他说，珍娜，你还记得我吗？我说，是的，史蒂夫，我对你的记忆就是你总是蹲在我的桌子底下处理我的电脑。他笑得前俯后仰。他说，嗯，
that was probably 80% of my job was just dealing with all of the computers at your desk. He said he was the one that was in charge of finally setting up the speaker on Oscar's desk. You remember? Yes. Yeah, all of that. So we really went down memory lane. But he also told me that he was in charge of all of the items on our desk, including all of the plants in the office. So here is what he told me about Pam's plants at reception. Wait, did you tell him that I'm obsessed with him? Yes. Because I had to explain why I was suddenly calling him to ask him multiple questions about the plants on the reception desk. I had to give some context. So he didn't think you were crazy. No, I mean, he might still think we're crazy. But I mean, he's like retired and living in Oregon
那可能占了我工作的80%，就是处理你桌上所有的电脑。他说他是那个负责最终在奥斯卡的桌子上安装扬声器的人。你记得吗？是的。是的，所有这些。所以我们真的顺着记忆的长河回味了一番。但他也告诉我，他负责我们桌上的所有物品，包括办公室里的所有植物。所以以下是他关于接待处帕姆植物告诉我的事。等等，你有没有告诉他我对他着迷？是的。因为我必须解释为什么我突然打电话给他，问他关于前台接待桌上植物的好几个问题。我得给点背景信息。免得他觉得你疯了。不，我的意思是，他可能还是觉得我们疯了。但我的意思是，他现在退休了，住在俄勒冈州
now. So all right, here is what he told me, Ange. So you might remember, he had a little office on our stages that was behind Michael Scott's office. Oh, yeah, I remember it. It was like a wooden, like they built him like a wooden shed right there. Yes. And lining his walls were all kinds of chalk keys and things that he would place all around the office. Yes. So right outside of his office, he had a tiny like grow station and a plant care station for all of the plants in the office. He said for Pam's desk, he had only about three different plants. And they were in plastic pots. And he would rotate them randomly. But he had an assortment, as we've noticed, of ceramic pots. So that was how he kind of tried to make them look different. He said that it was absolutely
呢。所以，好吧，安吉拉，以下是他告诉我的事。所以你可能还记得，他在我们的片场里有一个小办公室，在迈克尔·斯科特办公室的后面。哦，对，我记得。就像是一个木制的，就像他们在那里给他搭建了一个木制的小屋。是的。他的墙壁两边排满了各种各样的粉笔钥匙以及他会摆放在办公室各处的东西。是的。所以在他的办公室外面，他有一个微型的小型育苗站和一个植物护理站，专门用来照顾办公室里的所有植物。他说对于帕姆的桌子，他只有大约三种不同的植物。它们在塑料盆里。他会随机轮换它们。但他正如我们所注意到的那样，有一套陶瓷花盆。所以这就是他试图让它们看起来不同的方式。他说这绝对是
totally random. What plant he put on the desk, because I asked him about the flowering plant for beach games. And if it was symbolic that Pam bloomed in that episode, and he laughed and he said no, that's just a wonderful coincidence. He told me that Greg was very, very strict about the set decoration, and that they were not allowed to change anything without Greg's permission. Tiny details, they would get in trouble. He said Greg never noticed the changing plants. And he never consulted Greg about the plants. It was his own little thing that he did each week, his own small active rebellion, different plants. Yes. Well, Steve, I noticed. Angela noticed, Steve. He said that he thinks he did a Christmas cactus once. And that over the holiday episodes, he would always
完全随机的。他把什么植物放在桌子上，因为我问过他关于海滩运动那一集开花的植物的事，以及帕姆在那一集里绽放是否具有象征意义，他笑了，说不，那只是一个美妙的巧合。他告诉我，格雷格对布景装饰非常非常严格，未经格雷格允许，他们绝对不允许改变任何东西。微小的细节，他们都会惹上麻烦。他说格雷格从未注意到植物的变化。而且他从未就植物咨询过格雷格。那是他每周自己做的小事情，他自己小小的积极反叛，不同的植物。是的。嗯，史蒂夫，我注意到了。安吉拉注意到了，史蒂夫。他说他觉得自己好像曾经做过一次圣诞仙人掌。而且在假期剧集期间，他总是
try to do something maybe a little different. But mostly it was just these little ferns. I will be looking for that Christmas cactus. Oh, me too. I got so excited. I was like, Oh, I don't think we've seen that yet. We haven't seen Christmas cactus. Everybody look out for Christmas cactus. I'm gonna have to go back to the Christmas episodes. But I do not remember a cactus. Well, here's the other thing he told me, Angela. He would have to water all those plants. And if we ever went on a week long hiatus, he would take all the plants off the set, and he would put them under grow lights. And Tom Melby would come and water them on our brakes. I believe that, Tom Melby. I believe that. That's so sweet. I remember Steve, he would walk over to accounting and water the plant that
会尝试做点也许有点不同的事情。但大部分时间就只是这些小蕨菜。我会去找那个圣诞仙人掌的。哦，我也是。我当时超级兴奋，心想，哦，我觉得我们还没见过那个呢。我们还没见过圣诞仙人掌。大家注意圣诞仙人掌。我得回去看圣诞剧集了。但我确实不记得有什么仙人掌。嗯，安吉拉，他还告诉我另一件事。他得给所有这些植物浇水。如果我们去度一个星期的假，他会把片场所有的植物都搬走，把它们放在植物生长灯下。而汤姆·梅尔比会在我们休息期间过来给它们浇水。我相信这一点，汤姆·梅尔比。我相信这一点。太贴心了。我记得史蒂夫，他会走到会计部，给会计部和前台之间的文件柜上的植物
was on the file cabinets between accounting and reception. And we would chit chat. Well, here's the other thing he told me. What? Not plant related. Steve Dusharer was also in charge of all of the plaques around the office. He made all of them, including that one that trolled Kelly Cantley. No. Yep. He was also in charge of the whiteboard by accounting. And he said he was the one who wrote that Steve was robbed after the Emmys that one year. Oh, I love it. Steve, look at you. You're like over there mixing up plants. You're writing secret messages on the message board. Yes. He told me that this job was just his favorite. And it was wonderful. And we just talked about what a special thing we had. And he retired when the show ended. He was like, I don't think it's going to
浇水。然后我们会闲聊。嗯，他还告诉我另一件事。什么？跟植物无关。史蒂夫·杜沙尔还负责办公室周围所有的铭牌。他制作了所有这些，包括那个嘲弄凯利·坎特利的铭牌。不会吧。是的。他还负责会计部旁边的白板。他说那年艾美奖之后，正是他在上面写了“史蒂夫被抢劫了”。哦，我太喜欢了。史蒂夫，瞧瞧你。你在那边摆弄植物。你还在留言板上写秘密信息。是的。他告诉我这份工作简直是他的最爱。而且太棒了。我们只是谈论了我们拥有多么特别的东西。他在剧集结束时退休了。他说，我觉得不可能
get better. And he retired. Steve, you're not wrong. You're not wrong. We've worked on other shows and we've had good experiences and things. But I have to say, it'd be pretty amazing to be able to just write off in the sunset after a show like the office because it was that special. Mm hmm. Well, lady, you know, you got me that Morgan Gasel watercolor of the Beasley's botanicals for Christmas, everybody. Angela got me this. I mean, I could not be more excited. This is Jenna's Christmas present from me. I got her Morgan. You're so talented. You painted all of Pam's plants. And Morgan gave me the original. She also gave me a painting of all of Angela Martin's weird blouses. Yes, I've seen that. Yes. And Jenna and a coffee mug of Pam's botanicals.
比这更好了。然后他退休了。史蒂夫，你没说错。你没有说错。我们参与过其他节目，也有过很好的经历什么的。但我不得不说，在像《办公室》这样的剧集之后能够功成身退，感觉一定非常棒，因为它是如此特别。嗯。嗯，亲爱的，你知道的，你给我买了一幅摩根·加瑟尔创作的《比斯利植物学》的水彩画作为圣诞礼物，大家。安吉拉给我买了这个。我的意思是，我兴奋得无以复加。这是珍娜从我这收到的圣诞礼物。我给她买了我。你太有才了。你画了帕姆所有的植物。而摩根把原作送给了我。她还送了我一幅安吉拉·马丁所有古怪衬衫的画作。是的，我见过那个。是的。还有珍娜和一只印有帕姆植物的咖啡杯。
Amazing. Amazing. Well, I sent a print of Beasley's botanicals to Steve as a thank you. Oh, that is so sweet. I thought the man in charge should have a print as well. Yes. Oh, I love that. He also sent me a photo of himself in his office on stage. And now that I've told you, I can send it to you. And guys, he said we can put it up on Office Ladies Pod as well. Oh, we will. And we'll put up some of Morgan's stuff so you can see in our stories. And this was wonderful. I loved it. And guys, if you want to get one, go over to Society Six. It's the number six and search for Beasley's botanicals and it'll pop up and you can get one yourself. Well, let's take a break. And then when we come back, we will really get into this episode. Michael is
太棒了。太棒了。嗯，我寄了一张《比斯利植物学》的印刷品给史蒂夫作为感谢。哦，太甜了。我觉得负责的人也应该拥有一份印刷品。是的。哦，我太喜欢了。他还给我发了一张他在片场办公室里的照片。既然我已经告诉你了，我就可以发给你了。而且伙计们，他说我们也可以把它发到“Office Ladies Pod”上。哦，我们会发上去的。我们还会发一些摩根的作品，这样你们就能在我们的快拍里看到了。这真的太棒了。我很喜欢。而且伙计们，如果你想要一份，去Society Six。数字6，搜索“Beasley's botanicals”，它就会弹出来，你就可以自己买一份了。好了，我们休息一下。等我们回来，我们要真正深入探讨这一集了。迈克尔
not going to react well to the pizza delivery. Oh, no, it's not going to be good. All right, we are back, everyone. And we are going to open this episode with Michael and Jim returning from their very short road trip where they got, I don't even think, outside of Scranton before realizing that they're not invited to the big New York party. So they come back and Michael makes a big announcement like he actually wanted to be at the Scranton branch party. He actually didn't want to go to New York, right? Yes. And Stanley's like, wait, so we're not going home early. Yeah, Michael's like, no, no. In fact, Michael calls Angela into his office. And he says to Angela, I want this party to be sexier, cooler and more important than the one in New York. And he gives
对披萨外卖的反应可不会好。哦，不，这不会有好结果的。好吧，各位，我们回来了。我们将以迈克尔和吉姆的回归来开启这一集，他们刚结束了非常短的公路旅行，我甚至觉得他们还没开出斯克兰顿，就意识到自己没有被邀请去参加盛大的纽约派对。所以他们回来了，迈克尔大肆宣布，就好像他真的想参加斯克兰顿分公司的派对一样。他其实根本不想去纽约，对吧？是的。斯坦利就说，等等，所以我们不是提前回家？是的，迈克尔说，不，不。事实上，迈克尔把安吉拉叫进了他的办公室。他对安吉拉说，我想要这个派对比纽约的那个更性感、更酷、更重要。然后他给了
her a list of demands. Yeah, let's just talk about this list for a minute. Okay. Now, remember, the party starts in one hour. Yeah, this is the list. Ready? Beer, light beer, streamers, orchids, better lighting, something made of ice, pizza, pizza with mushrooms, pizza without mushrooms, white pizza, steak, chocolates, someone famous, cool music, confetti, go-go dancers, maybe Al Roker. Yeah, guess what? Michael says he'll get the pizza since Angela's gonna do all those other things in one hour. Yeah, I mean, he wants the people in New York to be jealous that they got Al Roker to attend in Scranton. How is that so hard to understand, Angela? I don't know. Just go get some go-go dancers and some steak, possibly change the whole lighting scheme of
她一份要求清单。好吧，我们来谈谈这份清单。好吧。现在记住，派对一个小时后开始。是的，这就是清单。准备好了吗？啤酒、淡啤酒、彩带、兰花、更好的照明、冰雕、披萨、加蘑菇的披萨、不加蘑菇的披萨、白披萨、牛排、巧克力、某个名人、酷炫的音乐、五彩纸屑、Go-go女郎（热舞女郎），也许还有阿尔·罗克。是的，你猜怎么着？迈克尔说他去买披萨，既然安吉拉要在短短一个小时内搞定所有这些其他事情。对，我的意思是，他想让纽约的人们嫉妒他们在斯克兰顿请到了阿尔·罗克出席。这有什么难理解的，安吉拉？我不知道。去找几个Go-go女郎和一些牛排，顺便可能改动一下办公室的整体灯光方案。
the office. That'd be great. Thanks. But he tells Angela, if anyone can do it, it's you. But actually, if there is someone who could do it better, could you let him know? What was it like for you to do that scene with Steve? Were you improvising any of the things on that list as you were reading them off or was that pretty much scripted? No, that was pretty much scripted. And it was really fun because Steve has to interrupt me. And I just loved, loved doing scenes with him. It felt like I got to be like in this comedic dance, you know? And except I'm dancing with like the best comedian in town, it just was so fun. I was like, you know how you have like a body buzz, you know? Yeah. Like I had that kind of feeling going in there to get to do scenes with him. And
那就太棒了。谢谢。但他告诉安吉拉，如果有人能做到，那就是你。但实际上，如果真有谁能做得更好，你能通知他一声吗？你和史蒂夫一起拍那场戏是什么感觉？当你宣读清单上的那些东西时，你是在即兴发挥，还是基本上都是按剧本演的？不，基本上都是按剧本演的。真的很有趣，因为史蒂夫必须打断我。我只是太喜欢、太喜欢和他演对手戏了。感觉我就像在进行一场喜剧舞蹈，你知道吗？除了我和城里最优秀的喜剧演员共舞，真的太有趣了。我就像，你知道那种身体酥麻的感觉吗？对。我就带着那种感觉走进片场去跟他演对手戏，
I loved every single second. And he would like, he would be so generous. We've talked about this, but he'd let me have a moment. Like when I say steak, and I look at him, you know, like he just let all of that breathe. I know exactly that body buzz you're talking about, because I would get that feeling every time I'd get a script and be like, oh, there's a Pam Michael scene. I get Steve all to myself. Yeah. And he's just so good. And I feel like every person in a scene with Steve, Steve makes that person better. Oh, yeah. Well, I love that scene. I watched it. I rewound it and watched it a second time, just because it was so, so delightful. Yes. And I had to memorize that list, guys. I'm not reading off. Oh my gosh,
我热爱其中的每一分每一秒。而且他会非常慷慨。我们讨论过这个，但他会让我留有发挥的空间。就像我说“牛排”的时候，我看着他，你知道的，他会让这一切都自由呼吸。我完全懂你说的那个身体酥麻的感觉，因为每次我拿到剧本，心想，哦，有一场帕姆和迈克尔的对手戏，我能独自拥有史蒂夫时，我就会有这种感觉。是的。而且他真的太棒了。我觉得每个和史蒂夫对戏的人，史蒂夫都会让那个人变得更好。哦，是的。嗯，我很喜欢那场戏。我看了。我倒回去看了第二遍，就是因为它太、太美妙了。是的。而且我得把那份清单背下来，伙计们。我不是在照着读。哦，天哪，
that wasn't written on the piece of paper for you. No, I mean, you know, like, I maybe the prop department had a list, but I had to learn that. Well, and it's important because some of those elements are going to come up later, right? So you had to make sure you said certain things. Yeah. Well, next up, Andy is trying to talk to Dwight to see, what does he think about Angela? Does he think that Andy should go after Angela? And Dwight is like, no. The first thing he says, which if you speak Dwight, you know, is one of the highest compliments he could give anyone. He says, she's efficient. Well, that's just like, that's like stabbing Dwight in the heart right there. Yeah. That he's lost such an efficient woman. Yeah. And, you know, Dwight does not
那不是写在纸上让你照读的吗？不，我的意思是，你知道的，也许道具部门有一份清单，但我必须把它记住。嗯，这很关键，因为其中一些元素稍后还会出现，对吧？所以你得确保自己说出了某些特定的台词。嗯，接下来，安吉拉正试图和德怀特谈谈，看看他怎么看待安吉拉？他觉得安吉拉应该和安迪交往吗？而德怀特说，不。他说的第一句话，如果你懂德怀特语，就会知道这是他能给予任何人的最高赞美之一。他说，她很高效。嗯，那简直就像，就像直接在德怀特的胸口捅了一刀。是的，他失去了这么一个高效的女人。而且，你知道，德怀特
obviously want Andy to make a play for Angela. So he tells her it's inappropriate to date someone at work. And, and he could actually date Kelly because she's in the annex, like he can date Kelly or Toby, but not anyone in their immediate bullpen. Yeah. Well, now Michael triumphantly announces that he has ordered pizza from everybody's favorite place. Everyone gets kind of excited until they learn that Michael ordered pizza from the wrong place. Well, you know, clearly the favorite of Dunder Mifflin is Alfredo's Pizza Cafe. And Michael has ordered from pizza by Alfredo's, which Kevin describes as like eating a hot circle of garbage. Well, Michael asks, what's better, a medium amount of good pizza or all you can eat of pretty good pizza? And everyone
显然不想让安迪去追求安吉拉。所以他告诉安迪，在工作场所约会是不合适的。而且，安迪其实可以去约会凯利，因为她在附属建筑里，他可以约会凯利或者托比，但绝对不能是他们核心办公区里的任何人。嗯，现在，迈克尔得意洋洋地宣布，他从大家最喜欢的地方订了披萨。每个人都有点兴奋，直到他们听说迈克尔从错误的地方订了披萨。嗯，你知道的，邓德米夫林员工的最爱显然是阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆。而迈克尔订的是阿尔弗雷多披萨店，凯文把它形容为就像在吃一个热腾腾的垃圾圈。嗯，迈克尔问，中等分量的好披萨和随便吃的大量还不错的披萨，哪个更好？每个人
is like a medium amount of good pizza. Yes. But Jenna, this sent me on one of the craziest deep dives I have done in the year that we've been podcasting together. Well, I hope that you're going to tell me some stuff about Alfredo's Pizza Cafe because we got a fan question about this. Oh, yes. And more, more information than you'll ever want to know. All right. Well, Catalina Rizzi and Paisley Zelladon would like to know our pizza by Alfredo and Alfredo's Pizza Cafe actual pizza places in Scranton. Well, Alfredo's Pizza Cafe is in fact a real pizza place. It's opened every day. It's still open in Scranton. And pizza by Alfredo is a made up place that the writers made up. But Alfredo's Pizza Cafe is in Scranton. And you can still get pizzas from
都说中等分量的好披萨。是的，但是珍娜，这让我开启了我俩做播客一年来最疯狂的一次深度挖掘。嗯，我希望你能跟我讲讲关于阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆的事，因为我们收到了一条关于这个的粉丝提问。哦，是的。还有更多，比你想知道的还要多的信息。好吧。卡塔利娜·里齐和佩斯利·泽拉东想知道，阿尔弗雷多披萨店和阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆是斯克兰顿真实的披萨店吗？嗯，阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆事实上是一家真正的披萨店。它每天都营业。它现在仍然在斯克兰顿营业。而阿尔弗雷多披萨店是编剧们虚构的一个地方。但阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆在斯克兰顿。你今天仍然可以从
there today. And Angela, I'll have you know Angela, the character could have ordered steak, because Alfredo's Pizza Cafe also serves steak, burgers and pasta. Oh yeah, it's a cafe. It's like a restaurant. Yes. Well, I was very curious. I just wrote in Alfredo's Pizza into my Google search. Okay. Because I was like, I wonder if this is just in Scranton, or do we have Alfredo's Pizza other places? Right? So here we go. In Homewood, Alabama, there's Alfredo's Pizza Cafe. In California, there's Alfredo's Pizza in Los Angeles. In Colorado, there's an Alfredo's Pizza in Denver. In Connecticut, there's an Alfredo's Restaurant Pizza in Gaylord'sville. In Delaware, there's an Alfredo's Pizza Gallery in Seaford. In Florida, there's an Alfredo's Pizza in restaurant
那里买到披萨。而且安吉拉，我得让你知道，安吉拉这个角色本可以点牛排，因为阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆也提供牛排、汉堡和意大利面。哦，对，它是家咖啡馆。就像一家餐厅。是的。嗯，我当时非常好奇。我在谷歌搜索里输入了“阿尔弗雷多披萨”。好吧。因为我想，不知道这只是斯克兰顿才有，还是其他地方也有阿尔弗雷多披萨？对吧？所以，我们来看看。在亚拉巴马州霍姆伍德，有阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆。在加利福尼亚州洛杉矶，有阿尔弗雷多披萨。在科罗拉多州丹佛，有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨。在康涅狄格州盖洛德斯维尔，有一家阿尔弗雷多餐厅披萨。在特拉华州锡福德，有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨画廊。在佛罗里达州库珀城，有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨餐厅
in Cooper City. In Illinois, there's an Alfredo's Pizza in Pasta in Lake in the Hills. In Iowa, there's an Alfredo Pizza. We'll let it slide, Iowa. That's in Sioux City. In Maine, there's Alfredo's Italian Pizzeria in Wells. In Maryland, there's Austria Alfredo in Easton. In Massachusetts, there's Alfredo's Italian Kitchen in Boston, Somerville, and Medford. In New Jersey, there's an Alfredo's in Cartourette. There's an Alfredo's Restaurant in Pizzeria in Point Pleasant. There's a Cafe Alfredo's in Somerset. In New York, there's an Alfredo's Pizza Cafe in New Rochelle. In North Carolina, there's an Alfredo's Pizza Villa in Chapel Hill. Alfredo's Restaurant Italiano in Clinton. Wait for it. In Ohio, there's Alfredo's Pizzeria in Salem. In Pennsylvania, there's Alfredo's
。在伊利诺伊州湖在山中，有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨意大利面。在艾奥瓦州，有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨。我们就放过你吧，艾奥瓦州。那在苏城。在缅因州韦尔斯，有一家阿尔弗雷多意大利比萨店。在马里兰州伊斯顿，有奥地利阿尔弗雷多餐厅。在马萨诸塞州波士顿、萨默维尔和梅德福，有阿尔弗雷多意大利厨房。在新泽西州卡特雷特，有一家阿尔弗雷多。在点普莱森特有一家阿尔弗雷多餐厅及比萨店。在萨默塞特有一家阿尔弗雷多咖啡馆。在纽约州纽罗谢尔，有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆。在北卡罗来纳州教堂山，有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨别墅。克林顿的阿尔弗雷多意大利餐厅。等等，还有。在俄亥俄州塞勒姆，有一家阿尔弗雷多比萨店。在宾夕法尼亚州，有一家阿尔弗雷多
Pizza in restaurant in Scranton. And Alfredo's Pizza in Grill in Swiftwater. In South Dakota, there's an Alfredo's Pizza in Vermillion. We'll let it slide, South Dakota. In Texas, there's Alfredo's Pizza in Pasta in Dallas. Alfredo's in Plano and Alfredo's in Louisville. Utah has Chef Alfredo's in St. George and Cedar City. Virginia has Alfredo's in Bristol. Now, are you ready for this? Who has the most that comes up in a Google search? West Virginia! West Virginia has Alfredo's in Somerville. Alfredo's Italian Pizzeria in Petersburg. Alfredo's Pizza of Rainville. Louisburg, White Silver Springs, Buckhannon, Alfredo's Italian and Greek because, okay, in Marlington. And Alfredo's in the Crossroads Mall in Mount Hope. I love you. There's
披萨餐厅在斯克兰顿。还有斯威特沃特的阿尔弗雷多披萨烤肉店。在南达科他州弗米利恩，有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨。我们就放过你吧，南达科他州。在得克萨斯州达拉斯，有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨意大利面。普兰诺的阿尔弗雷多披萨和路易斯维尔的阿尔弗雷多。犹他州圣乔治和锡达城有厨师阿尔弗雷多。弗吉尼亚州布里斯托尔有阿尔弗雷多。现在，你准备好听这个了吗？谷歌搜索结果里出现最多的是哪个州？西弗吉尼亚州！西弗吉尼亚州萨默维尔有阿尔弗雷多。彼得斯堡的阿尔弗雷多意大利比萨店。雷因维尔的阿尔弗雷多披萨。路易斯堡、怀特西尔弗斯普林斯、巴坎农、阿尔弗雷多意大利和希腊餐厅，因为，好吧，在马林顿。以及芒特霍普十字路口购物中心的阿尔弗雷多。我爱你。到处都是
Alfredo's everywhere. I love you. There's Alfredo's everywhere. Guys, I watched Angela as she listed all of the Alfredos, and it was three pages long. Well, if I didn't say your state, it's because there was no Alfredo's that came up in the Google search, but I looked up every single state. Well, you know, the one in Scranton is not actually called Alfredo's Pizza Cafe. It's just called Alfredo's Cafe. That's right. And it says their slogan. Please tell me their slogan is, we're not a hot circle of garbage. Because if that's not their slogan, it should be. Here is Alfredo's Cafe slogan. We're not fine dining. We're just fine food. I like it. I still think not a hot circle of garbage might be something they should consider. Well, Alfredo's, you heard it
阿尔弗雷多。我爱你。到处都是阿尔弗雷多。伙计们，我看着安吉拉列出所有的阿尔弗雷多，足足有三页长。嗯，如果我没说出你的州，那是因为在谷歌搜索里没有跳出阿尔弗雷多，但我查了每一个州。嗯，你知道的，斯克兰顿的那家其实不叫阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆。它只叫阿尔弗雷多咖啡馆。没错。而且它上面写着他们的标语。请告诉我他们的标语是：我们不是一个热腾腾的垃圾圈。因为如果这不是他们的标语，那就应该改成这个。以下是阿尔弗雷多咖啡馆的标语。我们不是高级餐饮。我们只是优质美食。我喜欢。我依然觉得“不是一个热腾腾的垃圾圈”可能是他们应该考虑的东西。嗯，阿尔弗雷多，你从珍娜这儿听到了，让你们的营销团队搞起来。是的，她说得没毛病。我想谈谈这一场戏里跟披萨完全无关的事情。
from Jenna, get your marketing team on it. Yeah, she's not wrong. I want to talk about something from this scene that has nothing to do with the pizza. Okay. Can we please talk about your weird ass blouse in this episode? Oh, Jenna. I'm sorry to curse, but guys, it is weird. It is so weird. And actually, now listen, later in the episode, I'm going to give you a time code that really zooms in on the sweater, in particular the part I want to talk about. But just know it's called the elbow poof. All right, well, I'll, I'll wait till we get to the appropriate time code. I can wait. Yeah, but it's, it's a bizarro sweater. It's got a poofy part at your elbow. Well, moving us along then, Angela, in this next scene, Phyllis comes in to the conference room to
好吧。我们能聊聊这一集里你那件怪里怪气的衬衫吗？哦，珍娜。我很抱歉说脏话，但伙计们，这真的很怪。太怪了。其实，听好了，在这集后面，我会给你一个时间码，它会特地放大那件毛衣，特别是我想谈的那部分。但只要知道它被称为“泡泡肘”就行了。好吧，那我，我等到合适的时刻再看。我可以等。对，但这件毛衣真的很诡异。你的手肘部位有一块泡泡鼓起的部分。好吧，那我们继续往下说，安吉拉，在接下来的这场戏里，菲利斯走进会议室，再次
confront Angela again. She maybe is using some of her techniques from the last episode on how to deal with difficult people. And she has placed items on post-it notes and then put a post-it note on each finger. And she says to Angela, you can pick one of these, one of these, I'll do one, but I can't do all of these. This is a her visual way of showing you how you've overwhelmed her with too many tasks. Well, let me tell you, this is some serious Phyllis asks, she wads them up, she throws them in my face. And I want you to know it did kind of hurt. That owl was kind of honest because when you crumple up paper, it's like pointy. Yeah. And also, I think that was the only usable take. I'm not kidding. Phyllis laughed every time she threw them in my face, she would
找安吉拉对质。她可能用上了上一集里学到的一些对付难缠之人的技巧。她在便利贴上写下了各种事项，然后把一张便利贴贴在每个手指上。她对安吉拉说，你可以挑一个这个，挑一个那个，我可以做一件，但我没办法把这些全干了。这是她向你展示你如何用太多任务把她压垮的直观方式。好吧，我告诉你，这绝对是菲利斯式的硬核操作，她把它们揉成一团，直接扔在我脸上了。我想让你们知道，这其实有点疼。因为纸揉成团之后，边缘挺尖锐的。而且，我觉得那其实是唯一能用的镜头。我没开玩笑。菲利斯每次把它们扔在我脸上时都会笑，她每次都会笑。所以对我来说，当我看着它时，我只是在回忆我们当时笑得前仰后合的场景，这让我感到无比幸福。嗯，每当菲利斯必须做这种事情时，她都做不好，因为这太违背她的天性了。这太违背她甜美、善良、充满爱心的天性了，以至于她只会咯咯直笑，她总是会笑场。是的。嗯，接下来，安吉拉，我们有这样一场戏，我有些问题想问你。安迪试图约安吉拉出去，而她却在翻找这箱派对用品。你觉得你会在里面找到什么？你在这个箱子里找什么？牛排？冰雕？你觉得迈克尔清单上的任何东西能有吗？更好的照明？那是个小箱子。那是装忙的箱子，珍娜。那是个能让我看起来很忙、从而可以忽略安迪的箱子。我给自己设定的心理活动是：显然，我在找更多那种奇怪的蓝色螺旋小玩意儿，我待会儿要把它们挂在会议室里。她脑海里浮现出蓝色螺旋小玩意儿的画面，她需要更多这种东西，所以她在拼命地翻找。但谁会把这当成搭讪台词啊？谁会觉得一个女人会停下手里正在做的一切，然后说，你说得对。这个箱子里没有烛光晚餐和电影。好吧，亲爱的，我们这里还有一个来自阿比·蒂尔福德的粉丝发现。
laugh every time. And so that to me, when I was watching it, I just was remembering us cracking up and it just made me so happy. Well, anytime Phyllis has to do something like that, she can't do it because it is so against her nature. It is so against her sweet kind, loving nature that she just giggles, she gets the giggles. Yes. Well, next up, Angela, we have this scene and I have some things to ask you about. Andy is attempting to ask Angela out, but she is searching through this box of party supplies. What do you think you're going to find in there? What are you looking for in this box? A steak? An ice sculpture? You think any of the things on Michael's list better lighting? It's a small box. It's a busy work box, Jenna. It's a box so I could look busy and I could
每次看都忍不住笑。所以我看的时候，就会想起我们当时笑得前仰后合的样子，这让我觉得特别开心。没错，每当菲利斯必须拍那种镜头时，她根本做不到，因为这太违背她的天性了。这太违背她温柔、善良、有爱的天性了，所以她总是忍不住咯咯直笑。是的。好了，接下来，安吉拉，我们有这样一个场景，我有些问题想问你。安迪试图约安吉拉出去，但她正在一堆派对用品的箱子里翻找。你觉得你能在里面找到什么？你在找什么？牛排？冰雕？你觉得迈克尔清单上的任何东西能有更好的照明吗？那是个小箱子。那是个装忙的箱子，珍娜。那是为了让我看起来很忙的箱子，我可以
ignore Andy. And what I gave to myself was like, clearly, I'm looking for more of those weird blue spiral thingies that I'm going to hang in the conference room later. She had a vision of blue spiral thingies and she needed more of them and so she's digging and digging. But who uses this as a pickup line? Who thinks that a woman is going to like stop everything she's doing and just be like, you're right. There's not dinner in a movie in this box. Well, lady, we also have a fan catch here from Abby Tilford. Okay, she says in launch party around 16 minutes 25 seconds. So this was a moment from last week's breakdown. Angela says she's been working on the party for two weeks. But now at 25 minutes 21 seconds, she says she's been planning it for three weeks. Is this just Angela
好吧，她说在发布会派对大约16分25秒的时候。所以这是上周剖析中的一个画面。安吉拉说她为这个派对已经筹备了两周了。但现在在25分21秒时，她说她筹备了三周。这只是安吉拉在演戏吗？这到底是什么？这算是一个连续性穿帮。我查了一下，她是对的。哦，不，她是正确的。这是一个连续性错误。也许我们可以为之辩解，说安吉拉突然觉得自己被压得喘不过气来。所以她可能夸大其词了。而且我还有一个即兴发挥的发现。我在走开的时候即兴说出了最后一句台词。我说，凯文又吃希腊菜当午餐了。我太喜欢了。那是即兴发挥。是的。那是即兴发挥。而且你看不到的是，马特·佐恩切到了扮演凯文的布赖恩的镜头，他就说，嘿，我太喜欢你的角色总是能找到某种微妙的方式来羞辱凯文了。是的，因为她觉得他整天都在那儿喋喋不休，是个挥之不去的烦恼。我跟你说，我觉得她就是要求的玻璃隔断。他把她逼疯了。她需要一个
being dramatic? What is this? This is a bit of a continuity catch. And I looked she's right. Oh, no, she's right. It's a continuity error. And maybe we can justify it by saying that Angela feels very put upon all of a sudden. So maybe she's exaggerating. And I have an improv catch. I improvised the last line as I walked away. I said and Kevin had Greek food for lunch again. I love that. That was an improv. Yes. That was an improv. And what you don't see is that Matt's own cut over to Brian as Kevin and he was like, Hey, I love that your characters go to is always to find some subtle way to insult Kevin. Yeah, because he was a constant annoyance for her constant all day long. I'm telling you, I think she requested the glass partition. He drives her crazy. She needed a
屏障。嗯，现在帕姆的毒舌时刻来啦。外卖小哥到了。帕姆打电话给迈克尔说，嘿，阿尔弗雷多披萨店的外卖小哥到了。迈克尔说，你没必要用那种语气说话。帕姆说，我用的是正常语气。我确实用的是正常语气的。我知道，但我就是喜欢帕姆的这种新状态。我陷入爱河了，帕姆。我完全不在乎。我有什么说什么。我太喜欢了。不过，对啦，外卖小哥到了。哦，天哪，这引发了迈克尔的一系列情绪崩溃。他对瑞恩的所有感受、那种被冷落、没有受到公正对待的感觉，全都要发泄到这个可怜的、只是个送披萨的 teenagers（青少年）身上了。是的，他很生气，因为这个披萨小子不接受他购买所有披萨的五折优惠券。他解释说，你只能享受两份披萨的半价优惠，
barrier. Well, now we have a little bit of PAM sass coming up. The pizza guy has arrived. And PAM calls Michael and says, Hey, the pizza bio Fredo guy is here. Michael says, you don't have to say it like that. And PAM says, I said it normal. I did say it normal. I know, but I just love that PAM this is this new. I'm in love PAM. I give zero Fs. I say what I think. And I loved it. But yes, the pizza guy is here. And oh, man, this starts a whole Michael spiral. Everything he is feeling about Ryan and feeling left out and not treated fairly, he is going to pile on this poor teenager who's just a pizza delivery guy. Yeah, he is mad because the pizza kid will not accept his half off coupon for all of the pizzas. He explains, you can have half off two pizzas, but
屏障。好了，接下来我们要迎来一点帕姆的毒舌了。送披萨的来了。帕姆打电话给迈克尔说，嘿，送阿尔弗雷多披萨的家伙来了。迈克尔说，你不用那样说话。帕姆说，我说的很正常啊。我确实说得很正常。我知道，但我就是喜欢帕姆的这种新状态。我是坠入爱河的帕姆。我完全无所谓。我心里想什么就说什么。我太喜欢了。不过话说回来，送披萨的来了。天哪，这引发了迈克尔的一连串情绪失控。他对瑞安的所有感受、那种被冷落、没被公平对待的感觉，他都要发泄在这个可怜的青少年身上，而对方只是个送披萨的快递员。是的，他很生气，因为这个送披萨的小伙子不肯接受他那张所有披萨都打五折的优惠券。他解释说，你两张披萨可以打折，但是
not all of the pizzas. And Michael is like, it doesn't say that anywhere on the coupon. And the pizza kid is like, I don't know what to tell you. I mean, he's basically like, if I give you half off all these pizzas, and I go back, I'm going to get in trouble. This is not, I mean, it's not my decision to make. I can't authorize your new use of this coupon. Well, and listen, the pizza guy does have a little bit of that teenage sass, though, because he's like, not my problem, a little bit full teenager sass. Listen, this truly isn't his problem. And Michael needs to lighten up. But the kid is also kind of an ass. For sure. Well, Michael's response to this is to have Dwight lock him in the conference room until he decides to honor the coupon. It's so irrational. He says
不是所有披萨。迈克尔就说，优惠券上根本没写这个。送披萨的小伙子就说，我不知道该怎么跟你说。我的意思是，他基本上是在说，如果我给你们这些披萨全部半价，我回去后就会惹上麻烦。这不是，我的意思是，这不是我能决定的。我不能授权你们这种新用法。听着，送披萨的家伙确实有点青少年的傲慢，因为他觉得，这不是我的问题，完全是一副青少年的傲慢。听着，这确实不是他的问题。迈克尔需要放轻松点。但那小子也确实有点混蛋。确实。好吧，迈克尔对此的反应是让德怀特把他锁在会议室里，直到他决定接受这张优惠券。这太不理智了。他说
that he needs to learn to about respect and accountability and follow through. He's saying all this crazy stuff. And then of course, he really loses it. And it's like, the guy is like, this is stupid. And he's like, you don't even know what stupid is, it's about to get us stupid up in here. This is such an outrageous storyline. As I was watching this episode, I just kept thinking, I can't believe we are doing this storyline. It is so funny. It is really broad. It's really broad. But yet at the same time, you kind of believe that Michael would do it. That Michael would be like, no, you're going to stay here and you're going to learn a lesson. And everyone around him is like, you have just kidnapped someone. You are currently holding
他需要学习尊重、责任感和贯彻到底。他说了一堆疯狂的话。然后当然，他真的气急败坏了。那家伙就觉得，这太蠢了。迈克尔就说，你根本不知道什么是蠢，这里马上就要有你受的了。这个故事情节太离谱了。当我看着这一集的时候，我一直在想，真不敢相信我们在演这个情节。太搞笑了。真的很夸张。真的很夸张。但与此同时，你又觉得迈克尔确实干得出来这事。迈克尔会觉得，不，你得待在这儿，你得吸取教训。而他周围的每个人都在说，你刚刚绑架了某人。你现在正扣押着
someone hostage. And he's like, no, no, no, I'm teaching him a lesson. Well, yeah, Kevin, Oscar Stanley, they have all started researching kidnapping and accomplices to see if they can be charged as, you know, accessories to Michael's crime. But this is what Michael does, you know, it's like in the episode when he drives his car in the lake, he takes it out on the guy who ate the turtles from the gift basket. He always like shifts the blame and responsibility. If Michael is embarrassed or if Michael is upset about something, he takes it out on a very ordinary moment. And it's so funny. And we've all sort of been there, right? We've all had that displaced anger. Like, I'll never forget one time my dad had, he had ordered this new barbecue grill and
某人做人质。而他却说，不，不，不，我在给他上一课。好吧，凯文、奥斯卡、斯坦利，他们都开始研究绑架和共犯了，看看他们是否会被指控为迈克尔罪行的同谋。但这就是迈克尔会做的事，你知道的，就像那一集里他把车开进湖里一样，他把气撒在那个吃掉礼篮里乌龟的家伙身上。他总是转移责难和责任。如果迈克尔感到尴尬，或者对某事感到沮丧，他就会把气撒在一个非常平常的时刻。这太搞笑了。我们其实都经历过这种事，对吧？我们都经历过那种情绪转移。比如，我永远不会忘记有一次我爸爸，他订购了一个新的烧烤炉，
Jenna, this guy in my hometown, makes them, you know, like a smoker, and he's a welder. And he made my dad the smoker. And it took him a while because he makes it, you know, by hand, he's out there welding. And my dad went to get it. And he got a flatbed trailer to put it on and pull it behind our truck. He was so excited. We'd waited so long. And he's driving down the driveway with it. And he didn't like factor in like the overhang of the carport and dented in the new smoker. Oh, no. Yeah. And for whatever reason, we were all like, don't say anything, don't say anything. He got out of the car and he was like, if that tree hadn't been there, then he was like going to cut down the tree. And my mom was like, it's not the tree's fault. Leave the tree out of
珍娜，我老家的这个人做的，你知道的，就像个烟熏炉，他是个电焊工。他给我爸爸做了那个烟熏炉。花了一段时间，因为他是手工制作的，他在外面焊接。我爸爸去取货。他弄了一辆平板拖车把它装上，并在卡车后面拉着。他太兴奋了。我们等了太久了。他正开着车把它拉进车道。他没有把车棚的悬空部分计算进去，结果把新烟熏炉给撞凹了。哦，不。是的。不管出于什么原因，我们都觉得，什么都别说，什么都别说。他从车里出来，然后说，要不是那棵树在那儿，然后他就像是要去砍树。我母亲就说，这不关树的事。别把树牵扯
it. You know, but we've all had these moments where we're so like upset and irrationally, we're like, that's it. It's the tree. Oh my gosh. Well, speaking of tree, that happened to me this year, Angela, we were all set to get our Christmas tree. Yeah. On this one day, we were going to set up the Christmas tree. And I can't remember what happened. It was like something and it was the night before. And I said to Lee, I said, so we're getting up early in the morning, we're going to go get our tree. We're going to decorate the tree tomorrow. And he said very casually, well, I don't know, I mean tomorrow or another day. And I was like, what? It's going to be tomorrow at 9am. And I like, I was like a mess. I was like, screaming and yelling. And he sat there and then he looked
进来。你知道的，但我们都有过这种时刻，我们感到非常沮丧，而且很不理性地觉得，就是这样。都是这棵树的错。哦，天哪。说到树，我今年也遇到了这事，安吉拉，我们准备好去弄我们的圣诞树了。对。就在那一天，我们要去摆放圣诞树。我不记得发生了什么。好像是什么事情，就在前一天晚上。我对李说，我说，我们明天一早起床，去拿我们的圣诞树。我们明天就要装饰这棵树。他非常随性地回答，嗯，我不知道，明天还是改天吧。我当时就想，什么？明天早上九点去。我当时就像个疯子一样。我大喊大叫。他坐在那儿，然后看着
at me and he said, babe, is it really about the tree or something else going on? Yeah. And then I was like, oh yeah. It was that the tree was the one Christmas tradition that I knew we could do in a pandemic. I could still put a tree in my house and I could decorate it and we could drink hot chocolate. I couldn't do any of the other gatherings or parties or seeing of people or seeing my family. All of my gift exchanges turned into zoom exchanges. And I had been holding on to this tradition of putting on Christmas music and decorating our tree. And the idea that we might not do it on that Saturday, but maybe we do it Sunday, I was like, I had a real, real big reaction. Yeah. So guess what? We got our tree that next day at 9am. Well, we went ahead
我说道，宝贝，这真的是因为树，还是有别的原因？对。然后我才反应过来，哦，是的。因为那棵树是我知道在疫情期间我们唯一能进行的圣诞传统。我仍然可以在我的家里放一棵树，我可以装饰它，我们可以喝热巧克力。我不能参加任何其他的聚会、派对、见朋友或见我的家人。我所有的礼物交换都变成了视频交换。我一直紧紧抓住这个传统，放着圣诞音乐，装饰我们的树。一想到我们可能不会在那个星期天做这件事，而是改到周日，我就有了非常非常剧烈的反应。好吧，你猜怎么着？我们第二天早上九点就拿到了树。好吧，我们还是去把它拿回来了，因为我们觉得，我们显然得给这个女人弄棵树来。好吧，我爸爸砍了那棵树上的几根树枝来清理车道。他说，尽管我们都知道是因为他没有测量，然后开进车棚把顶部给撞凹了。所以我们都当过迈克尔。你们大家，我们都当过迈克尔。而且，在情况好转之前，事情会变得更糟。好吧，是的，德怀特和迈克尔走进会议室，他们质问送披萨的那个小伙子。他是个孩子。他是个青少年。他们有点像在审讯他。他又不是这家公司的老板。他又不定价格。他听着，送披萨的家伙只是觉得，你们可以滚蛋了。他根本不买账。好吧，我们不得不问凯文，跟史蒂芬·雷恩一起拍这些审讯的戏是什么感觉，因为他们的行为太荒谬了。伙计们，凯文是这么说的。这绝对是我的第一份工作之一。这绝对毫无疑问是我做过的最大的一项工作，尽管它只是一集。这是世界上最大的一部电视剧之一。我最记得的一件事是，显然，能跟史蒂夫合作我非常紧张和害怕。但我跟其他人合作同样也很紧张。因为有一点，我觉得我当时17岁。我是唯一的孩子。其他人都是，你知道的，非常成熟的人。我觉得我好像骗了所有人，让我上了这部剧。而每个人都那么优秀。我不明白
and got it because we was like, we clearly need to get this woman a tree. Well, my dad cut down a few limbs off that tree to clear the driveway. He said, even though we all know it's because he didn't measure and he pulled into the carport and he dent it in the top of it. So we've all been Michael. We've all been Michael, you guys. And, and yeah, and it's, it's going to get worse before it gets better. Well, yeah, Dwight and Michael go into the conference room and they confront this pizza guy kid. It's a kid. He's a teenager. And they're sort of like interrogating him. He doesn't own the company. He doesn't set the prices. And he that he listen, the pizza guy is just like, you guys can kiss my ass. Like he's not having it. Well, we had to ask Kevin what it was like to
然后拿到了，因为我们当时觉得，显然我们得给这位女士弄棵树。好吧，我爸爸砍掉了那棵树的一些树枝来清理车道。他说，尽管我们都知道其实是因为他没量好尺寸，把车开进车棚时把车顶给撞凹了。所以我们都成了迈克尔。大家伙儿，我们都成了迈克尔。而且，而且，是的，这情况在好转之前还会变得更糟。好吧，是的，德怀特和迈克尔走进会议室，他们质问这个送披萨的小伙子。他是个孩子。他是个青少年。他们有点像在审问他。他又不是公司老板。他又不定价格。而且他听着，送披萨的家伙就像是，你们俩少来这套。总之他根本不吃这一套。好吧，我们不得不问凯文，那种感觉是什么样的
do these scenes with Steven Rain interrogating him because they are being so ridiculous. And guys, here's what Kevin had to say. It was definitely one of my first jobs. It was absolutely without question the biggest job I had ever done, even though it was just one episode. It was on one of the biggest TV shows in the world. And I just remember more than anything. Obviously, I was very nervous and scared to work with Steve. But it was just as I was just as nervous to work with everybody else. Because there's something about one, I think I was 17 years old. I was the only kid. Everyone else was, you know, a fully realized person. And I feel like I had tricked everybody into letting me get on the show. And everybody was just so good. And I did not understand how
和史蒂芬·雷恩一起拍这些审问他的戏，因为他们的行为太荒谬了。伙计们，凯文是这么说的。这绝对是我的第一份工作之一。毫无疑问，这也是我做过的最大的工作，尽管它只是一集。这是当时世界上最大的电视剧之一。我最记得的，莫过于其他一切。显然，我很紧张，害怕和史蒂夫合作。但我对和所有人合作同样感到紧张。因为有那么一回事，我想我当时17岁。我是唯一的孩子。其他人，你知道的，都是成熟的大人了。我觉得我好像骗了所有人，才让我得以出演这部剧。而且每个人都那么优秀，我简直不明白怎么
they could keep a straight face. And rain Wilson and Steve would ad lib the craziest, craziest stuff. And I, you know, locked in a room and rain would just be yelling at me. And watching it back, I'm frowning almost every scene I'm in, because that was my only way to stop from breaking. And that was the only thing I really, really remember in terms of working with them specifically, because I was just trying not to break because they're obviously comedic geniuses. That's very funny. And he's 17 in this scene, you guys. Yeah, I would not have that kind of composure at 17. I'm so impressed by that. No, I mean, I was 30 years old when I got my job as Pam on the office. I couldn't imagine if I had been 17 years old and paired with someone like
他们怎么能忍住不笑。雷恩·威尔逊和史蒂夫会即兴发挥最疯狂、最疯狂的东西。而我呢，被锁在一个房间里，雷恩一直在对我大喊大叫。回看的时候，我几乎在每个镜头里都在皱眉，因为那是阻止我笑场的唯一方法。这也是我特别记得与他们合作的事情，因为我只是在努力不笑场，因为他们显然是喜剧天才。这太搞笑了。伙计们，他在这场戏里才17岁。是的，我在17岁时可没有那种镇定。我对此印象深刻。不，我的意思是，我作为《办公室》里的帕姆找到工作时已经30岁了。我无法想象如果我当时17岁，并且在这些场景中与
Steve Carell and rain Wilson in those scenes, I couldn't have done it. I know, I know. Same. Well, now, you know, Angela interrupts sort of Dwight's interrogation. She comes in very matter of factly and says, I have to hang these. I mean, because if she didn't hang those two blue spirals. Yeah. Yeah, what would happen? She literally walks in holding two little blue spirally decorative things. That's it. But she has to come in. She has to hang them. Yeah. Yeah. And it's going to take her all of 45 seconds. But Dwight looks at her longingly and the pizza guy is like, why are you looking at her like that? He's like, he's such a punk. I love this kid. Well, now there's a scene coming up Angela that I love because Kevin
史蒂夫·卡瑞尔和雷恩·威尔逊这样的人搭档，我根本做不到。我知道，我知道。一样。好吧，现在，你知道的，安吉拉打断了德怀特的审讯。她非常公事公办地走进来，说道，我得把这些挂起来。我的意思是，如果她不把那两个蓝色的螺旋装饰挂起来的话。对。对，会发生什么？她手里 literalmente 拿着两个小蓝色的螺旋装饰物走进来。就这些。但她必须进来。她必须把它们挂起来。对。对。而且这只用花她45秒钟。但德怀特渴望地看着她，送披萨的家伙就说，你为什么那样看着她？他就像个小混蛋。我太喜欢这小子了。好吧，现在有一场戏要来了，安吉拉，我很喜欢，因为凯文
is going to have a moment where he takes charge. He's hungry. He is. He walks into Michael's office and he says, listen, everyone is hungry. And we would like to make a request that we order the good pizza so that we can eat it while we're waiting for the hostage negotiation over the bad pizza to end. I mean, this is the most sort of. Yes. Yeah. Have we ever seen Kevin take a stand before? I feel like the time we really see who Kevin is outside of the office is when he plays poker with his hat and drums and clearly when it comes to pizza. Yeah. Strong feelings. Strong feelings. Well, let's take a break because when we come back, the party is in full swing. Yeah. Who's that woman from the other office who's going to judge Angela's party? Oh, Denise
要有一个挺身而出的时刻。他饿了。他是。他走进迈克尔的办公室说，听着，大家都饿了。我们想提出一个请求，那就是订好吃的披萨，这样我们就可以在等待关于难吃披萨的人质谈判结束时吃它。我的意思是，这是最某种程度上的。是的。我们以前见过凯文表明立场吗？我觉得我们真正看到办公室之外的凯文是谁的时候，是他戴着帽子打扑克、打鼓的时候，以及很显然是在谈到披萨的时候。是的。强烈的情感。强烈的情感。好吧，我们休息一下，因为当我们回来时，派对正在全速进行。对。另一间办公室里那个要对安吉拉的派对评头论足的女人是谁？哦，布法罗的丹尼斯
Stimms and Buffalo. I don't know. Damn you. Damn you, Denise. All right, we'll be back. Well, we're back in the conference room. The party is underway. Angela really wishes she had just had one more hour. One more hour to hang more blue thingies. Yeah. And possibly get, you know, some dancers or something. Meredith says she thinks it looks good. Meredith is so nice to Angela in this moment. Yeah. She's trying to build her up. She's like, I think it looks great. And Angela just was like, well, that describes a lot. I don't know what she says. Angela says, well, that's why you're never in charge of these things. So snarky. So sassy and snarky. Yeah. So uncalled for. This is why no one is nice to Angela, by the way. You have given me grief. Why doesn't Pam help Angela?
斯特姆斯。我不知道。该死。该死，丹尼斯。好吧，我们马上回来。好吧，我们回到了会议室。派对正在进行中。安吉拉真的很希望她能再有一个小时。再有一个小时来挂更多的蓝色小东西。对。并且可能弄来，你知道的，一些舞者什么的。梅雷迪思说她觉得这看起来不错。梅雷迪思在这个时候对安吉拉太好了。对。她试图给她打气。她就像，我觉得这看起来棒极了。而安吉拉只是觉得，嗯，这话说得很符合你的风格。我不知道她说了什么。安吉拉说，嗯，这就是为什么你永远不会负责这些事情。太尖酸刻薄了。太傲慢又尖酸刻薄了。对。太不讲道理了。顺便说一句，这就是为什么没有人对安吉拉好。你一直在给我找麻烦。为什么帕姆不帮安吉拉？
Why isn't Pam nicer to Angela? Because anytime anyone tries to be nice to Angela, Angela sasses them. Well, isn't Angela just having her moment here, her moment of cutting down the tree branches? She is upset and she's going to take it out on Meredith. But then Andy's got a surprise. Andy walks in, rolls in, I should say, this humongous ice sculpture. And you guys, it was huge in real life. In real life, it was enormous. I don't know if it really does it justice, like on TV, watching it. It was so big. It was two swans kissing in the shape of a heart. Yeah. Yeah. I remember they had a bunch of them and they had them in this big walk-in freezer on these carts and they would have to wheel them in because they would sit there then in the background for a while and
为什么帕姆对安吉拉不更好一点？因为每当有人试图对安吉拉好的时候，安吉拉都会对他们冷嘲热讽。好吧，安吉拉在这里不就是在经历她的时刻吗，她砍树枝的时刻？她心烦意乱，她要把气撒在梅雷迪思身上。但接着安迪有个惊喜。安迪走进来，推着，我应该说，推着这个巨大的冰雕。伙计们，现实生活中它真的很大。在现实生活中，它大得惊人。我不知道它是否真的像在电视上看到的那样能体现出它的真实大小。它太大了。那是两只交颈亲吻的天鹅，呈心形。对。对。我记得他们有很多这样的冰雕，把它们放在一个大的步入式冰柜里的推车上，他们不得不把它们推进来，因为它们会在背景里放上一会儿，然后
they'd have to change them out. Yes. So Phil Shea had to place an order for multiple swan-heart giant ice sculptures. And you have to know that there was probably a meeting between Phil and Greg where there was a flip book of all the different ice sculptures he could order. Yes. This is the one they settled on. 100%. Well, I texted Jen Salata and I was like, Jen, what was the backstory of this ice sculpture? Like Andy says he stole it. Was there any backstory that we didn't get to see? And Jen said her idea was that Andy went into a wedding reception and stole this. That he stole it from a wedding reception. Isn't that hilarious? That explains the heart shape swans kissing for sure. Yeah. But I thought that was a really
他们必须把它们换掉。是的。所以菲尔·谢伊不得不订购多个心形天鹅巨型冰雕。你一定知道，菲尔和格列格之间可能开过会，当时有一本翻页画册，上面有他可以订购的所有不同冰雕。是的。这是他们最终选定的。百分之百。好吧，我给珍娜·索拉塔发了短信，我说，珍，这个冰雕的背景故事是什么？就像安迪说的是他偷的。有什么我们没看到的背景故事吗？珍说她的想法是安迪走进了一场婚礼接待处，偷了这个。他是从婚礼接待处偷的。这难道不搞笑吗？这绝对解释了心形天鹅亲吻的造型。是的。但我认为那是一个非常
funny little detail. Well, listen, the virtual part of this party is about to begin. I have to say it was so crazy in this new world of zooms and, you know, virtual meetings that we're in right now to see this webcam, multiple webcam party. Yeah. Because back then this would have been just very cutting edge. Very cutting edge. And, and now it's all we do. It's the only way I see you. We're doing this right now, closet to closet. That's right. Well, Pam tells Michael that Ryan is going to introduce him in a few minutes. And when that happens, they're going to cut to our conference room and all Michael has to do is smile and wave. Yeah. And Michael's like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. You know, you know, it's not going to go well. Well, in the meantime, Jim
有趣的小细节。好吧，听着，这个派对的虚拟部分就要开始了。我不得不说，在我们现在身处的新世界里，有Zoom和虚拟会议，看到这个网络摄像头、多个网络摄像头的派对，真是太疯狂了。对。因为在当时，这绝对是非常前沿的。非常前沿。而现在，这就是我们所做的一切。这是我看到你的唯一方式。我们现在正在这样做，衣帽间对衣帽间。没错。好吧，帕姆告诉迈克尔，瑞安几分钟后要介绍他出场。当那发生时，他们会切到我们的会议室，而迈克尔只需要微笑挥手。对。迈克尔就说，对，对，对，对。你知道的，你知道的，这不会顺利的。好吧，与此同时，吉姆
very charmingly invites Pam up on the roof. He said he's going to grab pizzas, tells her to grab some napkins and plates and stuff. And they go up on the roof and they have a rooftop dinner date. Yeah. Well, this is a callback to the client episode when Pam and Jim sneak up to the roof after they've read Threat Level Midnight and they share some grilled cheese sandwiches. Now they're going to go up and they're going to share some pizza. And they're also going to talk about when they knew that they liked the other person, right? Because now they're dating. Now they're not these star cross lovers. Now they're actually a couple. And I thought that was kind of interesting to find out for sure. Pam was there first. We find that out in the scene. Yes. But then there's
非常迷人地邀请帕姆去屋顶。他说他要去拿披萨，让她拿些餐巾纸和盘子什么的。然后他们去屋顶，进行了一场屋顶晚餐约会。对。好吧，这是对那一集《客户》的致敬，当时帕姆和吉姆在读完《最高机密》（Threat Level Midnight）后偷偷溜到屋顶，分享了一些烤奶酪三明治。现在他们要上去分享一些披萨。他们还要谈论他们是什么时候知道自己喜欢对方的，对吧？因为他们现在在约访。现在他们不再是那种苦命鸳鸯了。现在他们真的是一对情侣了。我觉得这挺有趣的，能确定这一点。帕姆去得更早。我们在那一幕中发现了这一点。是的。但后来还有
other episodes where Jim talks about Pam's first day. What? It's incomplete conflict. Ah, yeah. Well, here in this scene, Jim says, do you remember what you said to me on my first day of work just before you walked me over to my desk? So clearly it's like Pam is showing him around. I know. But I'm telling you there's another episode where Jim says I remember when Pam first came into the office. Oh, continuity error. That's a big one. That's a big story point. I like the idea personally that Pam worked there first. It makes sense to me. And I love this moment when Pam goes, yeah, I said to you, enjoy this moment because you're never going to go back to this time before you met your deskmate, Dwight. And then Pam says that she knew that she liked Jim
其他的集数，吉姆谈到帕姆的第一天。什么？这是前后矛盾。啊，是的。好吧，在这里的这场戏中，吉姆说，你还记得我上班第一天，你带我走到办公桌前之前对我说的话吗？所以很显然，就像帕姆在带他参观一样。我知道。但我告诉你，还有另一集，吉姆说我记得帕姆第一次走进办公室的时候。哦，连续性错误。这是一个大错误。这是一个重要的故事节点。我个人喜欢帕姆先在那儿工作的设定。这对我来说说得通。我喜欢这个时刻，当帕姆说，是的，我对你说，享受这个时刻吧，因为你再也回不到遇到你的邻桌德怀特之前的这段时间了。然后帕姆说，她知道自己喜欢吉姆
when he warned her that her mixed berry yogurt that she was about to eat was expired. And you know what? I get it. Me too. I get it because he had so just observed her, seen her, knew her. It's just such a like window into how much attention he paid to her. Well, listen, when Lee and I first started dating, there was this moment where I had moved into a new place and I wanted a grill. Speaking of grills, you were talking about your dad's getting his big grill. His big, yeah. So I got this grill and it needed to be assembled. And I was a little bit like, Oh, but I guess I'd been talking to Lee all about how excited I was to barbecue because it would, it reminds me of home. My dad grilled a lot, you know, and he taught
是在他警告她，她正要吃的混合浆果酸奶已经过期的时候。你知道吗？我懂。我也是。我懂，因为他一直在观察她、注意她、了解她。这简直就像是一扇窗户，能看出他对她倾注了多少关注。好吧，听着，当我和李刚开始约访时，有过这样一个时刻，我搬进了一个新地方，我想要一个烤炉。说到烤炉，你刚才在说你爸爸买他的大烤炉。他的大烤炉，是的。所以我买了这个烤炉，它需要组装。我当时有点觉得，哦，不过我想我一直在对李说，我有多兴奋能烧烤，因为它会，它让我想起家。我爸爸经常烧烤，你知道的，他教
me how to grill. So he said, Hey, how about I go over to your place while you're at work and I'll put together that grill for you. And we could grill some food when you get home from work. And I was like, really? When I got home from work that day, there he was in my backyard. He had put together the grill. He had broken down the box. Oh, that's got rid of the breaking down the boxes every day. Come on. Come on. Getting rid of the mess. I mean, the giant box. It's the box was as big as me. Yeah. And then he had marinated some chicken for us to grill. That is the moment I knew I am probably going to marry this man. This is amazing. And I'm sure that Lee, if he asked me and was like, what was the moment you knew? And I was like, it was that day that you broke down the box
我怎么烧烤。所以他说，嘿，你上班的时候，我去你那儿把那个烤炉给你组装起来怎么样？等你下班回家，我们就可以烤点东西吃。我当时就想，真的吗？那天我下班回家时，他就在我的后院里。他把烤炉组装好了。他把纸箱拆了。哦，太棒了。每天都要把纸箱拆掉。得了吧。得了吧。把乱七八糟的东西清理掉。我的意思是，那个巨大的纸箱。那个纸箱跟我一样大。是的。然后他还腌了一些鸡肉让我们烤。那就是我知道我可能会嫁给这个男人的时刻。这太棒了。我敢肯定，如果李问我，就像是问我什么时候知道的，而我说，就是你那天为烤炉把纸箱拆了的时候。他会说，原来是那个时刻。好吧，听着，组装一个烤炉可不是开玩笑的。我曾——做过那个。我协助过，那就像在组装一架小型赛斯纳飞机。有那么多零件。然后还要清理所有的残局，得了吧。当然，你会觉得，我觉得这个家伙是个潜力股。是的。听着，所以我明白帕姆的心情。那是日常生活中心灵手巧、美妙绝伦的细节。那是亲密感。真的是这样，他连她的酸奶都记着。太可爱了。好吧，我上班需要开很长一段车。我当时通勤时间很长。乔斯送了一张混合音乐CD，因为我说过我的音乐库里没有太多音乐。我在这方面真的很差劲，伙计们。比如我会听到一首歌并喜欢它，但我从来不会把它放进播放列表里，然后
for the grill. And he was like, that was the moment. Well, listen, building a grill is no joke. I have like done that. I've assisted and it's like building a small Cessna. It's so many parts. And and then to break down all the mess, come on. Of course, you're like, I think this one's a keeper. Yes. Listen, so I get where Pam is coming from. That is a sweet, wonderful detail of everyday life. That's intimacy. It really is that he tracks her yogurt. It's adorable. Well, I had a really long drive for work. I had a long commute coming up. And Josh dropped off a mix CD of music, because I was saying I didn't have a lot in my music library. I'm really bad about that, you guys. Like I'll hear a song and like it, but I don't ever put it in a playlist and then
音乐就乱七八糟的。可能实际上，当我这么说的时候，你可能会觉得，安吉拉，这听起来非常符合你的人设。就像，是的，如果我可以把我喜欢的所有的歌写在100张不同的便利贴上。但乔斯为我长途通勤制作了这个驾驶播放列表，我就觉得，这也太贴心了吧。是的，伙计们，这就是细节决定成败。是的。我们喜欢那种东西。拆个纸箱，做个播放列表。你就成功了。如果你想让你老婆真的对你动心。哦，天哪，开始啦。不用别人提醒就主动去倒垃圾。在垃圾满出来之前把它倒掉。你知道我的意思吗？在你想把它硬塞进去之前把它倒掉。没错。然后给她倒一杯
music's all over the place. It probably actually, as I say it, you're probably like, Angela, this sounds very own brand. Like, yes, if I could write all the songs I like on 100 different post-it notes. But Josh made me this driving playlist for my long commute, and I was like, that is so stinkin' thoughtful. Yeah. Guys out there, it's the little things. Yeah. We like that stuff. Break down a box and make a make a playlist. You're in. If you want to like really get your wife turned on. Oh, Lord, here we go. Take out the trash without being asked. Take it out before it's overflowing. Do you know what I mean? Take it out before you've like tried to cram it back in. That's right. And then pour her a
葡萄酒，然后像是不经意地引导她走过那个空了的垃圾桶。你绝对就成功了，我跟你说，如果你想追到像我或安吉拉这样的女人，不用别人要求就去倒垃圾。你就把我们拿下了。或者注意到我买的新地毯，然后说，哦，天哪，宝贝，你买新地毯了吗？我太喜欢了。这太棒了。我会觉得，或者这样呢？你知道吗？你非要买的那些额外的圣诞季节抱枕真的让这个地方充满了家的感觉。哦，哦，天哪。是的。你注意到了我的季节性抱枕。伙计们，我们告诉过你们，对吧？试试这些方法中的一种，然后给我们写信讲讲你们当晚的经历，因为这绝对管用。好吧，给我们概述一下你们当晚的经历。
glass of wine and like subtly walk her past the empty trash can. And you're in telling you, if you want to land a lady like me or Angela, take out the trash without being asked. And you got us. Or notice the new bath mat that I bought and be like, oh my gosh, babe, did you get a new bath mat? I love it. It's fantastic. I'm like, or how about this? You know what? Those extra Christmas seasonal pillows that you had to have really made the place feel homey. Oh, oh my gosh. Yes. You notice my seasonal pillows. Guys, we're telling you, right? Try one of these things and then you write us about the night you had because it's on. Well, give us the overview of the night you had.
只要告诉我们它管用就行。我不需要所有的细节，珍娜。不，我不要细节。请不要发主动发送的私密照片。哦，天哪，谁在要照片？现在你把这个画面植入他们的脑海了。什么的照片？他们当晚的照片。那太不合适了。这就是为什么我说不要发。我不要照片。我不要细节。只管告诉我。哦，天哪，伙计们，这招管用。好吧。现在派对真正开始了，我们在32分58秒看到了一点对一个角色的致敬。我们看到了丹·戈尔，区域经理。他回来了。现在我们要说到斯克兰顿将获得欢呼的时刻了，对吧？这就是迈克尔说的。他说，嘿，我觉得你应该知道，我的一位销售员打败了你们那台愚蠢的电脑。所以受着吧，
Just tell us it works. I don't need all the details, Jenna. No, I don't want the details. Please no unsolicited picks. Oh my God, who's asking for pictures? Now you put that in their brain. Pictures of what? Their night. That's inappropriate. That's why I'm saying don't send them. I don't want photos. I don't want details. Just tell me. Oh my God, you guys, it worked. Okay. So now the party is really underway and we see a little bit of a call back to a character at 32 minutes 58 seconds. We see Dan Gore, the regional manager. He's back. And now we're coming up to the point where Scranton is going to get its shout out, right? This is what Michael says. He says, hey, I just think you should know one of my salesmen beat your stupid computer. So take that
混蛋。是的。然后凯文拿着他的披萨，把它砸在电视屏幕上瑞安的脸上。那是斯克兰顿在这个公司活动中的高光时刻。等等，然后那个送披萨的小伙子跑向网络摄像头，说他是个未成年人，被违背意愿非法扣押。是的。为什么这个分部的任何人还能保住工作？我不知道。我不知道。但与此同时，就在这一切发生的同时，安迪试图挠安吉拉的背。安迪，你的招式是什么？告诉我，你用什么招式来吸引一个女人对你感兴趣？首先，你用一些荒谬的搭讪台词，比如电影院包厢里的那一套。然后你走到一个其实并不太熟的人身后去挠人家的背。你疯了吗？好吧，她说她有个地方痒，够不着。她确实说过。但我不
asshole. Yeah. And then Kelly takes her pizza and smashes it onto Ryan's face on the TV screen. That's Scranton's moment in this corporate event. But wait, then the pizza kid runs up to the webcam and says that he's a minor being held against his will. Yes. How does anyone in this branch still have a job? I don't know. I don't know. But meanwhile, just as all of this is going on, Andy tries to scratch Angela's back. Andy, what are your moves? Tell me, what are your moves to like get a lady interested in you? First, you have ridiculous pickup lines, like the movie in the box. And then you go up to someone you don't really know and scratch their back. Are you crazy? Well, she said she had an itch she couldn't reach. She did. But I don't
觉得那是个邀请。是的，那可不是邀请，安迪。除非别人邀请你挠背，否则别去挠别人的背。而且安吉拉看起来明显毫无兴趣。然后有一场戏，珍娜，我非常喜欢。那是我们节目常有的一场戏，我也很喜欢。它从来不作解释。只有德怀特和安迪站在男洗手间外面。从德怀特的整个身体姿势来看，他显然在戒备。所以我们只能假设送披萨的小伙子在里面上厕所。他被带进去了。然后安迪和德怀特在男洗手间外面进行了整段对话。有一会儿，德怀特一脚踹开门说，除非你在上大号，否则你只剩下大约15秒钟了，大意是这样。我不得不说，
think that was an invitation. No. Yeah, that wasn't an invitation, Andy. Don't go scratching people's backs unless you're invited to scratch their back. And Angela definitely does not seem interested. And then there's a scene, Jenna, that I love. It's something our show does that I love. It's never explained. It's just Dwight and Andy standing outside the men's room. Dwight is clearly on guard by his whole physical posture. So we're just left to assume pizza guys in there on his bathroom break. He's been led in there. And Andy and Dwight have this whole conversation outside the men's room. And at one point Dwight kicks open the door and says unless you're going number two, you've got about 15 seconds left or something to that effect. And I just have to say
我真的很喜欢雷恩在这里的选择。比如他踹门的方式，他看起来非常严肃。是的。我觉得雷恩在这场戏中的表演太棒了。全都是这些小细节。他有点高兴，对吧？因为安吉拉拒绝了安迪。他仍然很沮丧。他仍然对安迪继续追求她感到难过。但同时他有工作要做。那就是确保送披萨的小伙子不会逃跑。好吧，德怀特这个角色是一个非常棒的角色，因为他全心全意地致力于成为迈克尔的副手。以至于过一会儿，他要审讯这个送披萨的小伙子。而迈克尔现在突然意识到他们做了什么——他们绑架了某人。他开始
I really loved Rain's choice here. Like the way he kicked the door, he looked very official. He did. And Rain, I feel like his performance in the scene is so great. It's all these little moments. He's slightly like pleased, right? That Angela has rejected Andy. He's still crestfallen. He's still upset that Andy wants to continue to pursue her. But yet he has a job to do. And that is to make sure the pizza guy doesn't escape. Well, the Dwight character is such a great character because he is so invested and committed to being Michael's number two. So much so that in a minute, he's going to be interrogating this pizza kid. And Michael is now going to suddenly realize what they've done that they have kidnapped someone. And he starts
吓得惊慌失措。德怀特花了一会儿才反应过来，因为他之前太专注于之前的选择了。但随后他对新的选择同样坚定不移，他支付了所有的披萨费用。是的，他对迈克尔太忠诚了。这确实有点让人毛骨悚然。这让我想起了《蝇王》。就像，你知道的，突然之间，你知道的，当人们盲目追随一个本不该追随的人时。然后那会把他们带向何方？他们能做出什么事？德怀特接下来还会对这个送披萨的小伙子做什么？好吧，这是一个如此疯狂的故事情节。我们谈过了。我觉得很大程度上这真的取决于凯文的出色表演。是的，我完全同意。他在整场戏里都表现得完美无缺。
freaking out. And it takes Dwight a second because he was so committed to the other choice. But then he becomes justice committed to the new choice and he pays for all the pizza. Yeah, he's so loyal to Michael. And it is a little bit like creepy. It's it reminded me a little bit of like Lord of the Flies. Like, you know, it's like, all of a sudden, you know, when people follow someone who they shouldn't be following. And then where does that lead them? And what are they capable of? What was Dwight going to continue to do to this pizza guy? Well, it's such a crazy storyline. We talked about it. And I feel like so much of it really hinges on Kevin's great performance. Yes, I absolutely agree. He was perfect all throughout
是的。我们刚刚问他，他对自己在节目中的时间有什么回忆。他是这么说的。我从整个经历期间获得的最大记忆或收获是，老实说，是每个人的慷慨和善良，每个人都竭尽全力地接纳我，张开双臂欢迎我。我每天都和，你知道的，很多演员一起吃午餐。我想他们，你知道的，我完全就像一条离开水的鱼。我想每个人都能看出来。这是那种你来到片场，他们欢迎你来到片场和排练，每个人都在欢呼的经历。这是我一直铭记在心的东西。我记得当我加入《欢乐合唱团》时，在某个时刻我突然意识到，哦，我现在处于他们的位置了，成为每周都在这部剧里的人。当有人来的时候，我需要像《办公室》的人对待我那样对待他们。每当我看到人们，看到凯特，看到明迪在活动现场或其他什么地方时。每个人对我都依然非常好。他们会走过来，说，哦，我太高兴了。《欢乐合唱团》现在这么火。这就是那种感觉，我加入了一部非常火的剧，而所有这些人都非常有名和成功，尽管我现在加入了一部成功的剧，我仍然觉得自己很像个粉丝。他们能走过来，并且总是对我和蔼可亲，把我当作平等的人对待。这是我永远、永远不会忘记的事情。我说“他们”，但我意识到其实就是“你们”，所以谢谢
the scenes. Yeah. And we just asked him if he had any memories from his time on the show. And here's what he had to say. My biggest memory or takeaway from the entire experience period was was honestly, the generosity and the kindness from everybody, everybody went out of their way to accept me to welcome me with open arms. I sat with, you know, a lot of the cast for lunch every day. I think they, you know, I was totally a fish out of water. And I think everybody could see that. And it's one of those things where you come on set, they welcome you to set and rehearsal and everybody cheers. And that is something that I've taken with me. And I remember going into Glee how it hit me at some point of like, Oh, I'm now in their position as the person
那些戏。是的，我们只是问他是否有什么关于他在剧组时的回忆。他是这么说的。我从整个经历中获得的最大的记忆或收获，老实说，是每个人的慷慨和善良。每个人都特意接纳我，张开双臂欢迎我。你知道的，我每天午餐都和很多演员坐在一起。我想他们，你知道的，我完全就像是个离开水的鱼。我想每个人都看得出来。这就是那种你来到片场，他们欢迎你来到片场和排练，每个人都在欢呼的事情。这是我一直铭记在心的东西。我记得去了《欢乐合唱团》后，在某个时刻我突然意识到，哦，我现在处于他们的位置了，作为那个
who's on this show every week. And when people come on, I need to treat them how the office people treated me. And whenever I would see people, see Kate, I would see Mindy out at events or whatever it may be. And everyone was just still so nice to me. And they'd come up and be like, Oh, I'm so happy. Like the Glee is doing so well. And it was one of those things where me coming onto a show that was so big, and all these people were so very famous and successful, that even though I was now on a show that was successful, I still felt very much like the fan. And the fact that they could come up to me and they just always treated me with kindness and as an equal. And that's something I will never, ever forget. And I say they, but I realize it's you, you guys. So thanks
你们对我这么好。你知道的，天哪，他能这么说太甜了。这真的让我想起了过去，当我还是个胸怀大志的演员，在剧集中获得那些客串角色时，这对我会是一件大事。但我去到片场时，会觉得自己非常孤单。是的。大多数时候，人们并不邀请我和他们一起吃午餐。他们生活在自己的世界里，因为他们每天都有那份工作。所以这对我来说并不是特别特别。我只会觉得自己，你知道的，真的是孤立无援的。我们谈过这个，就像第一天去新学校的孩子。是的。伴随着新的一天、新的地方、新的工作以及这一切带来的所有压力。是的。而且人们通常不会特意去
for being so nice. You know, lady, it's so sweet for him to say that. And it really takes me back because when I was an aspiring actor, and I would get those guest star roles on shows, it would be such a big deal to me. But I would go on the set and I would feel just so alone. Yeah. And most of the time, people didn't invite me to eat lunch with them. And they were in their own world because they had that job every day. So it wasn't particularly special to them. And I would just feel, you know, like I was really on my own. We've talked about it like a kid in a new school on the first day of school. Yeah. With all the pressure of like the new day and the new place and the new work and all of it. Yeah. And people did not generally go out of their way to try to
让我感觉好受一些。这也没什么。但我认为我们《办公室》剧组的所有人在这一行混了那么久，经历过那种感觉太多次了，所以每当有客串演员来时，我看着每个人都会特意去自我介绍、打招呼、握手，邀请那个人和他们一起吃午餐，带他们去零食区。我确实有这样的记忆，我们是如此热情好客。就像是，欢迎来到我们的家。让我们带你四处转转，带你参观一下。你知道洗手间在哪吗？我想这是因为我们所有人在这一行待了太久，都经历过相反的待遇，所以我们希望我们的节目能有所不同。我们就是这么做的。我们从不挂在嘴边。这只是我们所有人共同
make me feel better. And that was fine. But I think all of us on the office had been knocking around for so long and had experienced that feeling so many times that whenever we did have a guest star, I would watch as everyone would go out of their way to introduce themselves, say hello, shake hands, invite that person to eat lunch with them, show them where the craft services was. I do have this memory of us just being so hospitable. It was like, welcome to our house. Let's show you around, give you a tour. Do you know where the bathrooms are? And I think it was because all of us had been around for so long experiencing it the other way that we wanted our show to be different. And we just did it. We never talked about it. It was just this collective
做的一件事。是的。你肯定会记得每一份工作，尤其是当你刚开始的时候，如果有哪怕一个人向你展现了善意，你都会记住它并铭记于心。我很高兴我们的节目对凯文来说是那样的，并且他把同样的哲学带到了《欢乐合唱团》。是的。这真的很酷。好吧，我们还问他，事到如今，尽管他已经出演了其他所有这些精彩的项目，他是否仍然被认出是《办公室》里的那个送披萨的小伙子。他是这么说的。我因《办公室》而被认出来的次数简直令人匪夷所思。真的。就像在《欢乐合唱团》拍摄期间，甚至在《欢乐合唱团》之后，我仍然有四分之一的概率是因为《办公室》而被认出来，
thing that we all did. Yeah. And you definitely remember with each job, especially when you're starting out, if there was one person that showed you kindness, you just like remember it and you hold on to it. And I'm so glad that our show was like that for Kevin, you know, and that he took that same philosophy to glee with him. Yeah. That's really cool. Well, we also asked him if he, after all this time, still gets recognized as the pizza guy from the office, even though he's gone on to all these other amazing projects. And here's what he had to say about that. The amount of times I get recognized for the office is mind boggling. Truly. Like even in the midst of glee, even after glee, I get recognized a solid quarter of the time from the office,
仅仅因为那一集。我拍了120多集《欢乐合唱团》，但我只拍了一集《办公室》，我被认出来的频率就是这么高。这绝对是完全不同的受众群体。你总是能分辨出来，但这依然让人惊讶，因为我也觉得，我的外貌变化挺大的。那已经是将近15年前的事了。所以我总是感到困惑。这每次都让我感到非常骄傲。是的。没错。我只上过那部剧一次，好吧，你知道的，四天。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。好吧，我很高兴他在剧里有这么棒的经历。我喜欢这种遗产对他来说一直延续着。让我们告诉你们在哪里可以在Instagram上找到凯文。他的名字就是他的全名，Kevin McHale。也就是 Kevin M C H A L E。而在推特上，他是 druid dude。D R U I D D U D E。
from one single episode. I did 120 something episodes of glee, but the one episode I did of the office, I get recognized that much. And it's absolutely a different demographic. And you can always tell, but it's still just surprising because I also, I think I look pretty different. That was almost 15 years ago. So I'm always baffled. And it's sort of makes me feel very proud every time. Yeah. That's right. I was on that show once, well, you know, four days. I love it. I love it. Well, I'm glad he had such a great experience on the show. And I like that the legacy has endured for him. Let us tell you where you can find Kevin on Instagram. He is just his full name, Kevin McHale. That's Kevin M C H A L E. And on Twitter, he is druid dude. D R U I D D U D E.
仅仅拍了一集。我拍了一百二十多集的《欢乐合唱团》，但我在《办公室》拍的那一集，我受到的认出率竟然那么高。这绝对是不同的观众群体。你总是能分得清，但它依然让人惊讶，因为我也，我觉得我看起来很不一样。那是将近15年前的事了。所以我总是感到困惑。而且每次都让我觉得非常自豪。是的。没错。我曾在那部剧里待过一次，好吧，你知道的，四天。我喜欢。我喜欢。好吧，我很高兴他在剧中有这么棒的经历。我喜欢这种遗产对他的延续。让我们告诉你去哪里可以在Instagram上找到凯文。他的名字就是他的全名，凯文·麦克海尔。就是凯文·M·C·H·A·L·E。而在推特上，他是druid dude。D·R·U·I·D·D·U·D·E。
Well, now Angela, we have my other favorite scene from this episode coming up with you in it again. I love that scene with you and Michael where he's giving you all of the instructions. And I love of when Andy comes over to serenade Angela over speakerphone with his acapella pals. This was, did you say acapella pals? Acapella pals. Acapella pals. His acapella pals. His acapella pals. Acapella what? My acapella pals. Yeah. This scene was so much fun to do. And oh my gosh, more went into it than you'll know. I mean, it was pretty like a tech heavy moment. Oh, for sure. Well, we actually asked Jen, how did she come up with this idea for the serenade? Or how did she pitch this idea? Because this was brilliant and so charming. And here's what she had to say.
好吧，安吉拉，接下来我们要迎来这一集里我最喜欢的另一个场景，你也在里面。我太喜欢你和迈克尔的那个场景了，他在给你所有的指示。我更喜欢安迪走过来，通过免提电话和他的无伴奏合唱伙伴们向安吉拉深情献唱。这是，你刚刚是说无伴奏合唱伙伴吗？无伴奏合唱伙伴。无伴奏合唱伙伴。他的无伴奏合唱伙伴。他的无伴奏合唱伙伴。无伴奏合唱什么？我的无伴奏合唱伙伴。是的。这个场景拍起来太有趣了。哦，天哪，里面付出的努力比你们知道的还要多。我的意思是，这几乎是一个科技含量很高的时刻。哦，当然。好吧，我们实际上问了珍，她是怎么想出这个小夜曲的主意的？或者她是怎么提出这个想法的？因为这太绝了，而且非常迷人。她是这么说的。
I remember pitching to Greg that Andy could sing take a chance on me to Angela with speakerphone backup singers. And Greg was like, cool, cool, go tell Ed so we can start thinking about how he'd want to sing it. And I walked down to Ed's trailer. And I'm just awkward in general. But then also, I had a bit of a fangirl thing because I loved Ed on The Daily Show. And I was still so excited that he was on the office. So I just awkwardly knocked on his trailer door and told him, hey, we're thinking about having Andy sing take a chance on me to Angela. And we just wanted you to start thinking about the song. He's like, what song? And said, take a chance on me, Mamma Mia, Abba. And he didn't know the song. And I'm thinking, oh God, how can you not know the song? Maybe slightly
我记得向格列格提议，安迪可以通过免提电话作为背景伴唱，给安吉拉唱《Take a Chance on Me》。格列格就说，酷，酷，去告诉埃德，这样我们就可以开始考虑他想怎么唱了。我走到埃德的房车前。我本身就有点笨拙。但除此之外，我还带点狂热粉丝的心态，因为我太喜欢埃德在《每日秀》里的表现了。而且我依然为他能出演《办公室》而感到兴奋。所以我只是有些笨拙地敲了他房车的门，告诉他，嘿，我们在考虑让安迪给安吉拉唱《Take a Chance on Me》。我们只是想让你开始考虑这首歌。他问，什么歌？我说，《Take a Chance on Me》，《妈妈咪呀》，阿巴乐队。而他居然不知道这首歌。我心想，哦，天哪，你怎么会不知道这首歌？可能稍微
predicting the horror that was about to come. And he's like, how does it go? And I am a terrible singer. I cannot sing at all. And so I was like, oh, you know, it's like, remember, Mamma Mia? And did you know the song? And I just tried to figure out how to say it without singing it. And then we ended up walking around the parking lot. And I had to sing take a chance on me to Ed. And it was so embarrassing, but so lovely. He was so wonderful about it. And I love that scene so much. I just thought he killed it and was so excited that that he was able to do such a fantastic job with it. It was just exciting. That would be me. I'd be so nervous if I all of a sudden I had to sing something to someone because I hate singing in front of people. I love to belt
预示了即将到来的噩梦。他说，这首歌怎么唱？而我是一个糟糕的歌手。我根本不会唱歌。所以我说，哦，你知道的，就像是，还记得《妈妈咪呀》吗？你知道这首歌吗？我只是在试图弄清楚怎么在不唱出来的情况下表达它。然后我们最终在停车场转悠。我不得不对着埃德唱《Take a Chance on Me》。这太尴尬了，但也太美好了。他对此表现得太棒了。我太喜欢那个场景了。我只是觉得他演得太绝了，而且非常高兴他能够把这个任务完成得如此出色。这太让人兴奋了。那肯定是我。如果我突然不得不给某人唱首歌，我会超级紧张，因为我在别人面前唱歌会感到很不自在。我喜欢放声高歌，你知道的，在浴室里，或者在厨房里和孩子们一起。但如果我不得不，你知道的，天哪，让埃德、史蒂夫或其他人来问，好吧，这首歌怎么唱？我会超级紧张和尴尬。好吧，我们还收到了来自珍·雷诺兹、萨拉·索鲁普、斯蒂芬·杰克逊、罗克珊·霍夫曼和贝卡·哈灵顿的大量粉丝提问。他们想知道是谁在电话里为安迪进行背景伴唱的。这是怎么做到的？他们当时真的在电话线上，还是预先录制好的？哦，珍娜，我的记忆是我们是实时完成的。我告诉你们为什么，因为我必须在那里做出反应。我想，无论你做什么，安吉拉，你绝对不能把这群人的拍摄搞砸，你知道的，
it out, you know, at home in the shower or like, just in the kitchen with the kids. But if I had to like, you know, oh my God, like have someone like Ed or like Steve or someone be like, okay, how does that go? I'd be so nervous and embarrassed. Well, we also got a lot of fan questions from Jen Reynolds, Sarah Thorup, Stephen Jackson, Roxanne Hoffman and Becca Harrington. They wanted to know who sang the backup on the telephone for Andy. How was that accomplished? Were they actually on the line or was it pre-recorded? Oh, Jenna, my memory is we did that in real time. And I'll tell you why, because I had to be there reacting. And I thought, whatever you do, Angela, you cannot mess this up for these guys, you know,
因为他们把时间都计算好了。我们实际上问了珍·索拉塔这件事。她是这么说的。我们在无伴奏合唱《Take a Chance on Me》中非常幸运请到的歌手之一是约翰·迈克尔·希金斯。你们会在克里斯托弗·格斯特的电影里认出他。他简直太才华横溢了。所以我们超级、超级兴奋。我不知道另一个歌手是谁。所以我试着去查证，但没有成功。我们，我相信我们是在当天录制的，当时约翰和其他不知是谁的人（除了约翰之外）呆在编剧们通常在片场休息的小办公室里。他们打进电话并通过免提电话演唱。然后我敢肯定我们还录制了一个干净的版本，不是通过免提电话唱的，这样我们就可以把它混入音轨中，然后只需
like, because they had it all timed out. And we actually asked Jen Salada about it. And this is what she had to say. One of the singers we were so lucky to get for the acapella take a chance on me was John Michael Higgins. You'll know him from Christopher Guest movies. He's just brilliant. And so we were super, super excited. I don't know who the other singer was. So I tried to track it down and I was unsuccessful. We, I believe we recorded it on the day in that John and whoever else maybe besides John were in the little office that the writers used to hang out on set. And they called in and sang through the speaker phones. And then I'm sure we recorded a clean version two of it, not through the speaker phones so that we could have it in the mix and then just
就像，因为他们把时间都算准了。我们实际上问了詹·萨拉达关于这件事的看法。她是这么说的。我们非常幸运能请到的一位无伴奏合唱《给我个机会》的歌手是约翰·迈克尔·希金斯。你会从克里斯托弗·格斯特的电影里认出他。他简直太才华横溢了。所以我们超级、超级兴奋。我不知道另一个歌手是谁。所以我试图追查，但没有成功。我们，我相信我们是在当天录制的，约翰和其他任何人——除了约翰之外也许还有别人——都在编剧们以前在片场聚会的小办公室里。他们打进电话并通过免提扬声器唱歌。然后我确信我们也录了一个干净的版本，不是通过免提扬声器，这样我们就可以把它放进混音里，然后只需
make sure that we got the sound quality great. But it was a really fun day. I just thought that they killed it. Well, I remember that, Angela, because I remember listening to Ed and those guys practicing before they divided up and went into the sort of speaker phone situation. Right, right. But it was a big deal. And what a big get for just this voice on the phone that has gone completely uncredited. I know. And I am such a fan of John's like he is such a comedic genius. And, and, and he and Ed and how they put this all together and did it was so fantastic. I loved every second of it. It was hard for me not to fully smile, because it was so charming and delightful. And, you know, Angela is trying not to tip her hand too much. She only has a very
确保我们的音质非常棒。但这真的是有趣的一天。我只是觉得他们表现太棒了。嗯，我记得那个，安吉拉，因为我记得听埃德和那些家伙在分开并进入某种免提电话的情况之前排队练习。对，对。但这是一件大事。而且对于这个完全没有署名的电话里的声音来说，真是一个巨大的收获。我懂了。而且我是约翰的超级粉丝，就像他是一个喜剧天才一样。而且，而且，而且他跟埃德以及他们是如何把这一切组合在一起并做到的，真是太棒了。我喜欢它的每一秒。我很难不完全笑出来，因为它是如此迷人和可爱。而且，你知道，安吉拉正试图不要透露太多。她只有非常
slight smile at like one or two parts, right? Yep. But I just I have such fond memories of this. And I just felt like we had to hear it. If you change your mind, I'll be first in life. Honey, I'm still free. Take a chance on me. If you need me, let me know. Gonna be around. If you got no place to go. If you're feeling down. If you're all alone. When the pretty birds have flown. Honey, I'm still free. Take a chance on me. Gonna do my very best in letting no lie. If you put me to the test. If you let me try. Take a chance on me. That's all I ask of you, Angela. I mean, I mean, come on. How they harmonize at the end like that. All right. I got goosebumps listening to that. I got a little choked up. I don't know if I just
在某一两部分只有微微一笑，对吧？是的。但我只是——我对这段记忆太美好了。我只是觉得我们必须听听这个。如果你改变主意，我会排在第一位。亲爱的，我仍然单身。给我个机会。如果你需要我，告诉我。会在你身边。如果你无处可去。如果你感到沮丧。如果你孤单一人。当美丽的小鸟飞走时。亲爱的，我仍然单身。给我个机会。我会尽我最大的努力不撒谎。如果你考验我。如果你让我试试。给我个机会。这就是我向你要求的全部，安吉拉。我是说，我是说，拜托。他们最后是怎么那样和声的。好吧。听了那个我都起鸡皮疙瘩了。我有点哽咽了。我不知道我是不是只是
miss Ed a lot. And he's charming in the scene. Yeah. Or if it's just the time we're in. I don't know. I've also just fallen in love with Andy during this rewatch. You know, we've talked about how I have this new appreciation for Ryan, right? Also just have been loving the character of Andy in his journey. But I don't know, Angela, I also have to say, I know I mentioned that the way to my heart is to put together a grill and break down the box. But I think that if there was a guy that I actually was not that interested in, if he did this, I would be like, okay, all right. It is so sweet. It's so, so charming. You know, my husband is a really good singer, and he doesn't really sing around people. But when we first started dating, we went out and
非常想念埃德。而且他在剧里很迷人。是的。还是说只是因为我们所处的时代。我不知道。在这部剧的重温中，我也已经爱上了安迪。你知道的，我们讨论过我是如何重新欣赏瑞安的，对吧？我也一直很喜欢安迪这个角色和他的旅程。但我不知道，安吉拉，我还得说，我知道我提过通往我内心的途径是组装一个烤架然后把纸箱拆开。但我认为，如果有一个我其实没那么感兴趣的家伙，如果他这样做了，我会觉得，好吧，行吧。这太甜了。这真是太、太迷人了。你知道，我丈夫是个非常棒的歌手，他其实不在别人面前唱歌。但当我们刚开始约定时，我们外出了
there was karaoke, and I didn't really know the side of him. He's like an a cappella guy. And he got up and sang Journey. And he brought down the bar and I was like, oh, my gosh. But it was just so, so sweet in this moment. Andy, you know, and Andy will go on to sing to Angela again. But you know, he must really like her if he's going to bust out the a cappella group. Yeah, he's all in. I hope one of those guys was Broccoli Rob. Oh, it had to have been. Yeah. And Angela just looks at him and says she has to go clean up the party. And then we reveal that the whole bullpen has watched this. Yeah. Including Dwight. Yeah. And before we move on, Jenna, 38 minutes, 15 seconds, prime elbow poof, prime elbow poof of the sweater. I don't even
那里有卡拉OK，我真的不知道他这一面。他就像个无伴奏合唱的家伙。他站起来唱了《Journey》。他震撼了全场，当时我就想，哦，天哪。但这在这个时刻真的是太、太甜了。安迪，你知道的，安迪后来还会给安吉拉唱歌。但你知道，如果他要亮出无伴奏合唱团，他一定真的很喜欢她。是的，他全力以赴。我希望其中一个家伙是西兰花罗布。哦，那一定是的。是的。然后安吉拉只是看着他说她得去打扫派对。然后我们透露整个办公区都看到了这一幕。是的。包括德怀特。是的。在我们继续之前，珍娜，38分15秒，黄金肘部泡芙，毛衣的黄金肘部泡芙。我甚至不
understand the sweater, you guys. It was skinny at the top, then had a big floofy poofy part right at the elbow, then skinny again down to the wrist. And it also had lace sewn in to the v-neck. Yeah, I mean, I think that we have to acknowledge that Andy serenaded Angela while she was wearing this terrible blouse. Yeah. No other man was going to hit on Angela today. Well, I'll tell you that because that blouse is a repellent. I think we have a callback to a flirty shade of beige here. Yes, very flirty shade of beige again. Yes. Well, actually, it's like a Victorian shade of beige with the poofy sleeve, right? Yeah. The poofy elbow. Dwight ogles her in this flirty shade of beige and Andy sings to her. So clearly something was working.
理解那件毛衣，伙计们。它顶部很紧，然后就在肘部有一个大大的蓬松部分，接着顺着手腕又变紧了。而且它的V领上还缝了蕾丝。是的，我的意思是，我认为我们必须承认，安迪在安吉拉穿着这件糟糕的衬衫时对她进行了小夜曲。是的。今天没有别的男人会搭讪安吉拉。嗯，我会告诉你为什么，因为那件衬衫是个驱逐剂。我认为这里有一个对调情米色调的呼应。是的，非常调情的米色调再次出现。是的。嗯，实际上，这就像是一种维多利亚风格的米色调，带着蓬松的袖子，对吧？是的。蓬松的肘部。德怀特在这个调情的米色调中对她眉目传情，而安迪为她唱歌。所以很明显有些管用了。
It's a shocker. Well, now we go into Michael's office and he and Dwight are just both miserable over this day. Yeah, they've had a day. And Michael says more than anything, he's bummed that he did not get to have authentic New York sushi. Not a thing. Yeah. New York has very good sushi. Yeah. But it is certainly, I don't think the sushi capital, but whatever, Michael is really, really bummed. Yeah. And he says to Dwight, I think we should go to New York and get that sushi. You're driving. Dwight is so excited. He can't wait. He can't wait to drive all the way to New York to crash the tail end of this corporate party and get the leftover sushi that no one else wanted to eat. That's been sitting out for a while. For a long while. I just want to say.
真是个惊吓。好吧，现在我们走进迈克尔的办公室，他和德怀特都为这一天感到无比痛苦。是的，他们度过了糟糕的一天。迈克尔说，最重要的是，他遗憾的是自己没有吃到正宗的纽约寿司。根本没有这回事。是的。纽约有非常好的寿司。是的。但这肯定，我不认为这是寿司之都，但不管怎样，迈克尔真的很、真的很沮丧。是的。他对德怀特说，我认为我们应该去纽约吃那个寿司。你开车。德怀特太兴奋了。他等不及了。他等不及一路开车去纽约，去大闹这个公司派对的尾声，然后吃别人都不想吃、已经放了一会儿的剩寿司。已经放了很久了。我只想说。
So that's what they do. They get there, they go into the party. They get kicked out pretty much immediately. There's no one there, but they grab a plate of sushi and then they go and they sit on the hood of Dwight's car. And guys, this, they did not go to New York to shoot this. Obviously, this is a little parking lot that they found in downtown LA. I believe I recognized it because I think I've shot there. They are just eating the sushi and they are making fun of Ryan. And someone leaves the party and says to Michael, Hey, that was pretty awesome. You know, when you called Ryan out like that. And it is, it's like all he needed, right? Yeah. He feels seen and they're having sushi and they're in New York and now he can go home and he sets the
所以他们就是这么做的。他们到了那里，走进了派对。他们几乎立刻就被赶了出去。那里没有人，但他们抓了一盘寿司，然后他们去坐在德怀特汽车的车前盖上。伙计们，这个，他们没有去纽约拍这个。显然，这是他们在洛杉矶市中心找到的一个小停车场。我相信我认出来了，因为我想我在那儿拍过戏。他们只是在吃寿司，并且在取笑瑞安。有人离开派对，对迈克尔说，嘿，那真是太棒了。你知道的，当你那样当众质问瑞安时。而且，这就像他所需要的一切，对吧？是的。他觉得自己被看到了，他们正在吃寿司，他们在纽约，现在他可以回家了，他把
tray of sushi and soy sauce on someone else's car and they go home. It's pretty amazing. And then we have just a little tag at the end. We just see Ryan in full douche mode winking at the camera from his New York party that's in full swing. Oh yeah. So pleased with himself. Well, I don't know if you thought about it, but the scene had basically three couples in it having intimate moments. We have Jim and Pam dinner on the roof. We have Andy and Angela serenading and accounting. And we have Michael and Dwight having dinner in a parking lot. Yeah. Very sweet. Very sweet. And we had one hostage, but we let him go. Well, guys, that was launch party part two. And a big thank you to Jen Salada and Kevin
一盘寿司和酱油放在别人的车上，然后他们回家了。这太棒了。然后我们在结尾只有一个小尾巴。我们只看到瑞安以完全混蛋的姿态向他的纽约派对的摄像头抛媚眼，派对正在火热进行中。哦，是的。对自己的表现非常满意。嗯，我不知道你有没有想过，但那个场景基本上有三对情侣在里面度过亲密时光。我们有吉姆和帕姆在屋顶共进晚餐。我们有安迪和安吉拉的小夜曲和会计。我们有迈克尔和德怀特在停车场吃晚餐。是的。非常甜蜜。非常甜蜜。我们还有一个质子人质，但我们放了他。好吧，伙计们，那是发布会派对第二部分。非常感谢珍·萨拉达和凯文
McHale and Steve Dusharer for all the behind the scenes details. Yeah, guys, thank you so much for always letting us reach out to get those details each week. We really appreciate it and and we're going to be doing it for like three more years. So don't get tired of us. Everyone check your DMs if you've ever had anything to do with the office, please check in. We'll be there. There's a good chance Jen and I are there saying, Hey, what's up? All right, guys, we'll see you next week. Take care. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Irwin, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer.
·麦克黑尔以及史蒂夫·迪沙雷尔提供所有的幕后细节。是的，伙计们，非常感谢你们总是让我们联系以获取每周的那些细节。我们真的很感激，而且我们将继续这样做大约三年。所以不要对我们感到厌倦。每个人都检查一下你的私信，如果你曾经和办公室有任何关系，请联系我们。我们会在那里的。珍和我很有可能会在那里说，嘿，最近怎么样？好了，伙计们，我们下周见。保重。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由欧文、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。
And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad free versions of Office Ladies, go to Stitcher Premium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的助理制作人是阿因斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡树》。要获取《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问 Stitcher Premium.com。要免费试用一个月 Stitcher Premium，请使用代码 office。本集尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。